there are many elections happening today
I hope many of you I hope you all went
out and voted and uh already we're
getting people calling shenanigans I
don't know how serious any of these
stories are but uh sure enough there's
something to talk about votes being
flipped in one uh uh one uh voting
location in Philadelphia people are
quite worried about this gas leaks being
reported uh some locations have needed
extended time but they're saying all of
this is being taken care of now I don't
think the big story here is necessarily
that these individual things happen but
that it's a preview of what's to come in
the next year and just think about
what's going to what's going to happen
when the stakes are a bit higher than
say like the governorship of a single
state when it's the president and when
it's Donald Trump we also got news on of
Trump's trial Trump tried to read a
disclaimer clause in court where it says
specifically in his contracts he's not
liable for inaccuracies and the judge
would not let him do it people are now
screaming bias because they already had
a summary judgment against him saying he
did commit fraud they don't care that he
actually has a document proving he
didn't it's fascinating we're going to
talk about that plus YouTube and
Facebook have censored the reporting
from Steven Crowder on the Nashville
trans Manifesto and of course we have
the release of infringed you guys got to
check it out before we get started head
over to
timcast.net tu's film infringed is now
available it's been up since this
morning
become a member to watch the full length
documentary share it with your friends
we are doing a massive marketing
campaign behind this because it is not
just about the excellent work advocating
for our right to keep in bare arms
defend ourselves and the Practical issue
of how it's important if we want to
protect ourselves it's also about just
helping build that culture and I think
you know we're going to do a massive ad
campaign because at the very least we're
going to get those commercials up across
YouTube and other platforms advocating
for your right to keep in be arms so if
you like the work that we're doing if
you watch the documentary already
already and you love it stay as a member
upgrade your membership and share with
your friends and if you haven't you
really do need to see it because it's
epic smash that like button subscribe to
this channel we're going to have that
members only uncensored show coming up
for you as well if you are a member but
tonight joining us to talk about all of
this plus the making of infringed gun
rights in America we've got Lauren
Southern and John DUIs Lauren what's up
hey thanks for having me it's definitely
a pleasure to finally see the film out
it's been a long time coming and all the
reactions have been incredible coming in
all positive that's right and and Lauren
in an act of uh celebratory Defiance
took our $5,000 CNAC and insisted upon
drinking from a paper cup that's right
some right now everybody who knows what
Louis the 13th is is probably throwing
up a little in their mouth as she
prepares to pour into a paper cup but
you know she wants to it's okay it won't
let me open it it's I know you want to
blashe against me there's a button you
push and it pops open no I just ripped
it open and I'm going to throw it in
this paper cup so Lauren of course is uh
uh documentary filmmaker I mean you want
to mention anything else about your work
you're doing work with tenant media now
we're all yes I'm with tenant media
which you are as well a very exciting
crew we've got Matt Christensen Taylor
Hansen Ruben Benny Johnson um yeah so
you can go check them out tenet media on
YouTube watch tenet now on the twitters
and I'll be doing videos and little mini
docs for them and hopefully some more
documentries for you as well but uh yeah
if you want to check out some of my
older film work I've done farmlands on
South Africa borderless on the migrant
crisis American Mirage uh Crossfire and
now infringed I've got quite the body of
work and the lovely John Dua has helped
me with a couple of those now three of
them three of them now yeah you did
Crossfire too you cross that's right who
are you sir what you do yeah well I'm
John DUIs I'm the guy who's behind the
scenes I'm behind the camera so it's uh
it's a real privilege and honor for me
to be in front of the camera for once
and uh you deserve the credit you do
right thank you for having supp this is
this is blasphemy right here but it's
become a meme because she drank papy
from a paper cup for those that don't
know that's like I don't know $1
thousand whiskey or is it bourbon I so
how much does this cost we earned this
we that okay you're pouring that's like
$300 I just poured $300 probably when
you go to bars they they use I like eye
droppers to to and and they very careful
about drops cuz uh but we we crack this
open when El finally secured Twitter and
became X I should try it John wants
summon an actual glass anyway they're
celebrating the release of the film we
also have philon hanging out hello
everybody my name is philab bonti lead
singer of All That Remains very failed
musician and uh anti-communist and
counterrevolutionary I'm Ian Crossland
happy to be here I got Richie Jackson's
gift uh this wild shirt thanks Richie
what's happening the Rockstar himself
and John good to see you luren obviously
awesome good to see you it's good to see
you guys in front of the camera thank to
my right is this man yeah
good to see you
man uh me just adjust this quickly uh
ready when you are Tim go let's get it
here's the first story from abc27 voting
machines in one Pennsylvania county flip
votes for judges an error to be fixed in
tabulation I love this a quick
correction for the beginning of the show
I said it was in in one location
actually voting machines plural in a
county were flipping votes they check
this out they say voters were asked to
decide whether Pennsylvania Superior
Court judges Jack penella and Victor
stabil should be retained for additional
10year terms the yes or no votes for
each judge were being switched because
of the error said Lamont clure the
Northampton County Executive if a voter
marked yes to retain Panella and no for
example first abill it was reflected as
no on Panella and yes on stabil or
however you pronounce that now look
they're saying it's going to be fixed
the question the first question I have
is what if no one noticed and more
importantly what if no one one noticed
any others how how are we supposed to
this this is a huge huge problem because
right now voter confidence is probably
at an alltime low considering 2020 and
even 2022 midterms and now with this
it's not even this check we got a bunch
of other stories here we go let me see
if I have a no no we're getting there
Nick sorder says one of the top five
most liberal voting precincts in
Kentucky has been cleared out due to a
supposed gas leak kentuckians are
currently at the polls voting to decide
whether or not they want to house their
Democrat Governor Andy Basher and
replace him with trump-backed Daniel
Cameron Highland Baptist Church in
Louisville will now be having extended
voting hours after being shut down we
have this one two Jefferson County polls
get extend extended voting time after
brief shutdowns so uh this is also this
is a related story we're uh we're we're
basically getting a a it's not
confidence building now I'll say it
right like I'll say it like this I don't
know if this matters in the big picture
these singular individual voting events
I think uh uh let me clarify I don't
know if right now just this one thing
matters I think together however and the
bigger picture matters is what I'm
trying to say if you're getting stories
like this and people already don't trust
the system it is going to shock
confidence in our elections which means
it doesn't matter who wins if the
Democrat wins the Republicans are going
to point to these and if the Republican
wins the Democrats going to point to
these Democrats will say things like
Republicans were so salty about 2020
they started manipulating with machines
and Republicans are going to say
Democrats are here doing the same thing
they've been doing I don't see when you
look at what's going on already and this
not even the biggest election day I mean
come on the primary voting is going to
be Bonkers we're I'm not even talking
about you know November 2024 the general
what's going to happen when people go to
vote in the primaries and they're
getting weird things happening what
happens when people go to vote in the
primary and a in a blue State's like oh
whoopsie you you didn't vote for Trump
you voted for dis santis or something
like that what you should do is
immediately stop release the software
code of that machine because they're
calling it an error and it was it an
error or was it supposed to do what it
did yeah it's it's really weird to me
how people of this very black and white
view of voter fraud it's like either
it's not happening at all and if you say
it's happening then you're an election
denier blah blah blah or it's like the
whole system is rigged and you might as
well not vote like of course voter fraud
is happening of course there are people
tampering Machines of course there are
people stopping ballots we know this
people have been charged for this in the
past and as we're seeing if you look at
polls over time of where people are at
on the political Spectrum everyone is
pushing further to fringes and as that
happens people are going to feel it is
more of a life ore situation to try to
rig elections of course they're going to
feel that way oh yeah if I change this
machine I'm literally saving trans lives
or I am literally saving the country
from you know whatever it might be so I
think we really need to be looking out
for this this doesn't mean don't vote at
all if anything I think the media are
the bigger election riggers than anyone
in this but um yeah there's a very real
phenomenon happening more than we
probably know this is why you need to
make sure you go out and vote this
there's two big things here one they
want to demoralize you for all you know
like for all the people who think
there's a conspiracy to steal votes
maybe the real conspiracies they want to
convince you not to vote I don't believe
they can rig an as every single machine
yeah now see this story this is really
demoralizing you mean even if I do go
out and vote they might flip my vote
don't fall for it don't fall for it
because
they when I say they I'm talking about
your political opponents and I don't
care who they are it's establishment
neol neocon all of them all the people
playing dirty politics want to convince
you not to vote so that they can win
it's like that episode of South Park
where they're voting for The Giant
douche and the turd sandwich and then I
can't remember what happened I think
like Kyle goes to Stan and he's like you
got to vote and he's like okay I'll vote
I guess he's like awesome wait who are
you voting for like I'm voting for the
other guy no wait don't vote they want
to convince you to vote but if they find
out you're going to vote for their
opponent they don't want you to vote I
think if these machines or are flipping
votes intentionally the more people that
vote the more likely it's going to get
found out that they're flipping votes so
you should definitely vote and pay close
attention and be volunteering like be
involved in your local elections be
involved in your local community half
the people that are volunteering are
going to be these activist types that
are on welfare that don't have jobs that
have all the time in the world you go be
involved in that we should be at our
local elections we should be you know
the volunteers there because that's
going to be how you're going to spot
this
stuff 20 next year is going to be wild I
don't even I don't even know where to
begin with it the fact that like there's
a lack of uh trust in estab the
establishment essentially um is I think
that the the lack of belief in in v in
the the soundness of the of the
elections that's that's baked into the
distrust of the The Establishment and
the more we we see people that are
skeptical or that are cynical about
voting or about the system the more
you're going to have things like people
see essentially confirmation bias
they'll they'll see something that seems
anomalous or seems weird and then
they'll be like well I know it's
definitely this cuz all it takes is one
small thing for people to be like now
I'm I've seen enough to have my previous
opinions confirmed and so now it's it's
not a you know now the whole thing
should be thrown away and that's just a
symptom of of having a A system that
people are very cynical about you know
people are extremely mistrusting of the
establishment media the establish with
when it comes to the government and it's
not just in the United States I mean you
guys were talking about what Canada's
like now and this is a phenomenal yeah
and this is a phenomenon that's
happening across basically the whole of
Western Society I I do think what Lauren
just said is consent to an American
invasion of Canada absolutely well it
would be of China you got to wait you
got to wait till Springtime all right
it's it's up there I just want to let
you know uh you do know the founding
fathers of the United States went to you
guys and said work with like you you
y'all were colonies too and our guys
were like you guys want to get in on
this and you were like nah we're
good we were burning down the White
House all right we still had a bit going
on for us British did he almost took
Montreal our ancestors saying did you
guys see the Canada election fraud stuff
with the Chinese interference no what
happines none of you guys we have like
had hard Lauren how many people live in
Canada like 30 something million how can
you guys not care about this you're
going to have a colony of China living
above you literally we're going to
remember when the Chinese Army went to
Canada and was like doing training
drills yeah literally and you guys don't
care about this when I was at the
airport three hours your board is 3
hours from my house in New Hampshire I
damn well care you know this yeah you
should not only were the ads the wait
times for my flights were all in Chinese
like we're Vancouver is becoming a
Chinese majority City right now and like
people are raising the Chinese Communist
flag at City Hall and police stations
and stuff it's kind of wild um but yeah
we've we've had a proven by CIS our
intelligence agency Chinese influence
campaign in Canada to win the election
for liberals donations um they've put
out ads for students and in Chinese only
ads encouraging people that are Chinese
in Canada to vote for Liberal
politicians and it's been and honeypots
have been deployed cus confirmed that
against poit Maple pot syrup pots in
Canada sir but full-blown full-blown and
this is just like not being talked about
how our elections are literally being it
happened in 2015 as well except it was
it was the us doing it in the 2015
election with Le things yeah for
liberals though it was like deep State
us it was they put you they they they
helped put uh you know James o had a
report power James had a report about uh
Chinese uh money flowing through act
blue I think you were something big
about that Lauren you were talking about
immigration is it is immigration you uh
largely from China in in Canada is that
the that's interesting we used to have a
large amount of particularly BC
Vancouver from Hong Kong but it's
flipped it's like you know in the single
percentages for Hong Kong and it's
mostly mainland China now coming to BC
Vancouver they call it hongcouver you're
not supposed to say that out loud but
you can't say anything up there it when
you literally have enclaves I was
getting my nails done at the airport
true story and the lady lives in
Richmond which is where the YVR Airport
is and she's like oh yeah I can't shop
at certain stores and she's not
particularly political she's just like
Richmond Richmond BC like Vancouver area
and she's like yeah they just don't want
me shopping there cuz I'm white and I
don't speak the language the local
language you look at um complexes being
built in Richmond and all of the
advertisements for buying are in Chinese
they're not in English I can show you
videos right now all of the housing it's
we are a Chinese Colony at this point so
what what is the voter fraud angle oh
well China is directly influencing our
elections in Canada they are deploying
um ad campaigns they're deploying
honeypots uh they're involv D in
offering tons of money to Liberal
politicians because they want to
continue to have large amounts of
control over our economy and um also
moneya laundering they call it snow
washing in Canada so tons of I think it
was um we have the same amount of moneya
laundering as uh the UK but we have
about a 3% success rate at uh actually
pursuing them legally compared to the UK
I've seen it from Al jazer this is from
September a couple months ago go Canada
what wases this say Canada opens inquiry
into allegations of election meddling by
China and Russia I also saw from
Bloomberg in 2021 uh China's alleged
election meddling creates problem for AP
AP reporting from September 2023 Chan
announces public inqu inquiry into
whether China Russia and others
interfered in elections yeah it's
there's a whole investigation into it
it's all confirmed the it was I think a
lot of it was broken by global no it
wasn't Global it was uh mlan I can't
remember Americans see here's what
happens in the uh revolutionary era re
the era of Independence the United
States there it wasn't just 13 colonies
everyone says the original 13 colonies
but they don't realize that British
colonies actually go extend up into
Canada there's many of them and the
founding fathers the same negotiations
they're having with say Florida or or or
South Carolina whatever are the same
negotiations they're having with Quebec
another British colony well up north the
Canadian what is now Canada was like
we're not interested in declaring
independence you're on your own so it's
actually a bunch of British colonies and
only some of them declared independence
so I think what you see here is the
United States more has more uh uh
descendants of of rebels it it was a
there were more people here who were
rebellious and willing to fight and die
for Independence than in Canada
absolutely Canada ends up with more
people who are willing to play ball
they're more willing to say look look I
don't want to get into a fight and this
opens the door to heavy soft power from
say China or Russia what are gun like in
China or in China what
are I want to make one more comment you
know what the most depressing part of
all of this is I don't even get my scam
calls in English anymore oh I'm that's
true in United States too my good friend
scam likely calls very often it always
leaves you a message you know that guy
too yeah scam what's he up to scam
likely that's his name you guys know
telemarketer they're always in Chinese
I'm like they they actually expect when
they call a Vancouver like phone number
they're like oh we're more likely to
reach a Chinese person
mandin I need to clearly you know what I
think that is I think that the uh this
is a big problem in the United States
and in North America in general where
we're all getting these random phone
calls it's been ongoing for a long time
when you answer it you get an automated
machine saying something in in Mandarin
you can't understand but understand this
for you as an individual having a minute
or two of distraction it's no big deal
with to your life but for the entire
country China can calculate the Mac
level when we run these Bots to phone to
call 7 million people per day we depress
the US economy by .2% or something like
this it is the macro effect as an
individual you don't care but on the
whole it could be massive I describe it
like Blackjack you know at the table for
the time it's basically a coin toss
between you and the house but that 05%
edge over the year means the casino will
make money same thing for China doing
these scam calls well you know what it
does too it makes people never pick up
phone calls you get a you get a call
from a business that's actually like
involved in your life and your community
wanting you to come out you're not
answering that no one answers their
phone we were just talking about this
this morning we don't answer our phones
anymore I don't I don't even have my
ringer on I keep my ringer off did you
guys hear about what happened with the
banks no that past week all these
different banks had payroll disruption
mhm and people think it's like oh so I
didn't get my payche for a few hours was
kind of annoying hold on let's say a
million people are expecting their
paycheck right when they wake up instead
they get it at 400 p.m. how many of
these people living to paycheck to
paycheck had a bill that was due that
day the same thing happened in Canada uh
few months ago with TD they they miss
payroll and I mean and there's people
who are moving into new homes and you
know rent I think trau even had to do a
statement about it and then what they
they charge people overdraft fees that W
get them that's Insidious if a bank
can't give you your payroll they cannot
charge you an good luck they don't
care your your Second Amendment right
your First Amendment right you
know the sixth Bank the sixth Bank this
year just collapsed in the United States
uh was it like Iowa savings and loan or
something like that just collapsed I got
to ask so the the American colonies
split off from the the Canadian colonies
long 250 years ago what what are gun
rights like in Canada from then to now
what have they what what was the what
was the establishment existence of
weapons rights there's you know it's
been pretty good but there's this short
period um when a certain politician got
elected that they all seem to disappear
overnight I can't true Trudeau right
yeah no immediately as he came in like
2020 they got rid of AKs m4s M16s 1500
weapons like all overnight gone um added
to restricted can't buy anymore and then
after the Uvalde shooting because of
course Uval day is in Canada and uh this
really affects us and the gun used was
definitely a gun that's legal in Canada
and not one that doesn't even uh any
made no sense he banned handguns uh
while we were filming the documentary
infringed so you can't purchase transfer
them anymore and this is going to keep
happening over and over they're floating
bills to ban things like the Plinkster
which is literally like you know to
shoot tin cans and they're talking about
banning these guns if Trudeau and the
Liberals stay in for another you know
they win the next
election it we're not going to have I
want to jump to the story which will
lead us into a bigger conversation about
uh gun control this is from the
post-millennial YouTube removes Steven
Crowder's reporting on trans Nash
Nashville shooter Manifesto claiming
violation of violent criminal
organizations policy so Crowder does
this big breaking story it is now
confirmed verified several pages of the
manifesto I should say of the journal
and documents from the individual
showing an anti-white motivation it may
not be the only motivation but it
appears to be that woke critical race
theory was a component of what drove the
individual to go and take the lives of
several children and faculty members now
right off the bed I just want to say
this I think one of the big reasons why
the the the mainstream press and many
political individuals uh politicians are
suppressing that story is not because of
the fear of the privacy or anything like
that violating privacy it's because they
always want to immediately jump to gun
control yeah anytime something like this
happens it's not what was the cause
behind us it was all that matters is
guns yet in Chicago guns don't really
matter in Baltimore it's not really it's
only when there's violent extremism and
I think the issue is whether it be even
whatever you describe identitarian
extremism whether it's Pro or anti-white
they want to use these things for
political gain and they want to uh they
want to push push away any
responsibility they may have for their
failed gun policy so I want to say as as
we start this segment shout out go go to
Tim cast.com watch infringed become a
member if you haven't already for those
that are just tuning in go to tim.com
right on the front page you will see a
Lauren Southern film infringed gun
rights in America it is nearly 2 hours
you got to watch it you guys uh did
amazing work on this but let's break
this down we've got YouTube has a bunch
of crazy rules on guns they take it very
very seriously now I think it's fair to
a certain degree right YouTube says no
live streaming any kind of gun content
and I'm like their concern is that
someone's going to go on a rampage but I
honestly don't think that makes sense
you can't post any kind of violent
criminal activity on YouTube at all why
ban live streams I think the big issue
YouTube Facebook and uh you know
probably Instagram they don't want
people promoting gun rights in the
United States or anywhere and they can't
just outright remove it but there have
been a bunch of issues that have
happened with uh with YouTube a while
and Google I remember this is a really
funny story back in 2018 YouTube banned
guns from shopping and they were so
stupid they banned Gundam do you guys
know what gundam is oh I know Gundam
Gundam is an anime and it's g n d and
they're giant fighting Japanese robots
in space and you and Google banned
people trying to buy it because they
were trying to suppress the word gun so
I certainly think it's overtly political
and they want to they they are working
let me just add this to it when we
learned uh a while ago but now with
confirmation from from the GOP that the
government is colluding with Stanford
University and big Tech organizations to
silence and suppress the rights of
individuals absolutely YouTube and
Facebook are taking a political stance
to suppress our rights first and second
I don't get is I feel like I see these
videos on YouTube of like a dude walking
into a shop and then the guy the shop
pulls out his weapon and Fires at the
guy and like they're all on YouTube what
what do you mean like movie what's that
like a movie no no like like security
camera footage of of a a guy com into
store are you sure cuz I
see like it'll be like a guy doing doc
talking about the video and then the guy
will walk in and he'll pull out the gun
and like if it's like a mainstream media
channel I remember after some of the
mass shootings that happened there were
and the whole monetization video um
issue came about on YouTube uh like
Jimmy Fallon tonight and Jimmy Kimmel
all of these people were able to do
videos about the mass shootings that
were monetized but no one else could so
you may have seen that on mainstream
media channels that have goad there are
a couple couple channels that do cover
that there's one called active self prot
protection which uh I forget the guy's
name but he actually covers
International stuff A lot of times
you'll have stuff from South America but
he it's always some kind of security
footage and you will go over what could
have been done better if it was an
actual self-defense shooting if it was
just it's probably not monetized though
um operator does
that million subscribers Donuts so I
think we yeah he I I don't want to talk
about the strategies people use to get
our we won isues yeah it's not
straightforward let's yeah no it's not
yeah and we know there are a lot of very
serious rules I remember that a bunch of
the big gun YouTubers were talking about
the restrictions that were placed and
they're weird and hard to understand but
I think it's fair to say YouTube taking
down this Manifesto serves nothing but
the gun control narrative in the left
liberal establishment narrative if if it
if it comes out it's it's not just about
guns don't at me wrong yeah it's also
about critical race Theory diversity
Equity inclusion it's like uh oh the
extremist ideology of the left is
resulting in extremist taking action as
a component there's more to this story
we haven't gotten the full release here
but I think a core component is there
are powerful interests that want to ban
guns in government and the private
sector and it is beneficial if you can
shut down any motivating uh any any
information on motivation so then when
no one knows what happened you can say
guess we got to ban guns y I'm concerned
that like and I always hate to pin it on
the CCP because I want the United States
and China to be allies long term but
like for them to be like hey alphabet
Google's parent company money money
money you want to you want to roll in
China we don't want you to have certain
uh gun rights things and like what are
they really trying to get the United
States to screw Itself by removing its
own amendments like come on like our our
constitutions more important than
corporate oligarchy and we cannot let
foreigners stop us from exercising our
rights and and cherishing our rights
yeah it's actually I mean there's always
the point of oh why arm yourself the
government's so powerful they'll just
nuke you whatever well it's actually
very hard hard to fight large you know
populations that are all armed and
spread out in a diaspora you know
whether you're in rice fields or in the
Middle East it's always proven difficult
and if you can just psychologically
disarm a population by convincing them
that they don't want or need or even
have these things in their awareness so
funny actually when I was checking in
for my flight on the way here there was
a sign behind us that said uh declare if
you have a gun and the Canadian guy
standing beside me was asking the lady
do a lot of people actually bring guns
from here couver and the lady was like
oh believe it or not they do and he's
like I thought no one owned them and
this was a conversation I witnessed they
want that to be the average person's
thought process they want the average
person to not even conceptualize or
conceive that why would I need a gun no
one does that longm it's a long-term
strategy right yeah so they they've been
largely successful I think honestly like
unless you're a person that
is it tends to be people that are pro
second amendment in the US they tend to
be people that are
also politically motivated politically
active there the reason that there
hasn't been success in the US with
significant uh anti-gun legislation gun
control the reason that there's been
victories for the past 20 or so years so
predominantly is because of the fact
that the people that are prun are so
politically active the idea that there's
a lot of money going to individual
Congress people from the gun industry
that's a fallacy the money that's going
to the to the the money that that is
actually big money is from rathon
they're making missile batteries they're
making drones they're making serious uh
you know the kind of Weaponry that's
sold to States the the companies that
make small arms generally don't have
these big contracts and they're not
giving tons of money the idea that the
NRA is responsible is a fallacy most gun
uh gun owners really look at the NRA as
a meme and as a joke and it's it's the
it's where all the fuds go you know so
the idea that that the the that it's
something other than Grassroots
preventing significant legislation
that's all a fallacy but I I think we're
winning yeah for sure we're so lucky
that the 20th century was televised and
recorded because what Hitler did was so
egregious he disarmed his population
then sent in the shock troops to control
them and that will never happen again
well I think you got a correction for us
sorry I think you got a correction for
what Ang just said Yeah well yeah it's
in the documentary that's right you know
there's a meme that says there's a meme
that says that Hitler um you know he he
he took all the guns right but it
actually started right after World War I
yeah and uh and and Germany you know you
know because they lost the war they they
had to uh they they had to abide by the
Treaty of Versa and in that treaty was
required that they disarm the citizens
so it was that was 1920 right 1919 1920
so it was the Allies that actually
required that of Germany to disarm the
pop so they disarmed the enemy so they
used a policy that was already in place
against the people and this is what's so
interesting is we always say like oh
we're we're going to put in these
policies for our side of politics like
for the lefties but you guys don't
realize that as soon as a government
that you really disagree with getson
power they can utilize those polit
policies against you here here's the
important Germany an important point
that was brought up in infringed in 1920
Germany's forced to disarm their
population in 1928 they reintroduce
permitting and gun registry you un own a
gun you got to prove why you that you
need it for a legitimate reason to
defend yourself and then you can apply
for a permit and register and then now
you're on list now you're on the list
and when the Nazis come to power they
have a list of everyone who is armed and
they start hunting those people down and
then of course the Nazis too they
relaxed gun restrictions for Nazi Party
members but then if you're a Jew you you
are not allowed to own a gun so again
gun control is not about
your safety gun control is not about
controlling guns it's about using guns
to control you and this is like why
these lists are so important too like
the Registries in Canada the long gun
Registries they tried to put in right
now actually um this January the ATF are
bringing in you need to register your
stabilizing braces with the ATF or you
need to hand in modified guns with them
these Registries are all to be
used real quick Phil didn't the the
Supreme Court overturn the the pistol
brace currently there is a stay on the
enforcement of the pistol brace it's
only for people that are members of Goa
and FPC which are both great uh great
proun uh organizations Firearms policy
Coalition and uh Gun Owners of America
but you have but they they have the the
actual uh lawsuit against the ATF and so
their members are are covered under the
state only their members only their
members so what if you sign up right now
you can join now and you will be a you
will be covered by the the stay but you
have to be a member of either the
Firearms policy Coalition it's gun
policy uh it's at gun policy on Twix and
uh or you have to be a member of Goa uh
both are great I'm a little partial to
Firearms policy Coalition because
they're a little more Hoist the Black
Flag kind of dudes and I like that um
but you have to be cover you have to be
a member of either of those two
otherwise a brace is currently a felony
and you'll get 10 years
$250,000 fine if you have a BRAC
uh an AR-15 they'll basically just
they'll be treating it as a short barar
rifle unless you're a member of those I
think I'm a member of like all of them
to be honest I think like one day I just
went to like every gun rights
organization started donating what does
it take to become part of it a donation
send give them your
information so like for for Canada to
have a gun license you have to have a
gun club that you're a part of or a
range that you're a member of right you
have to have your pal your R pal if you
want to own anything that's got some
real Firepower kick behind it and um you
got to have like your ammo guns separate
guns have to be locked a trigger lock on
them ammunition you know what do you
guys have any of that comparable yes
depends where we have we have a handful
of states that uh people refer to as the
Evil
7 he's right yeah and um you know when I
lived in New Jersey we had some some
security you know uh uh concerns and
this is before I bought a gun so I decid
you know I I need to get a gun why well
the cops told told me I I was told by a
cop if it were me I'd answer the door
with a shotgun that's all he didn't say
go buy a gun he was like you know what
I'm saying and I'm like okay and then I
was told by the police if someone were
to try to break into my home I can do
nothing if someone is actively at my
door smashing out the window and
reaching and open the door I cannot take
action against that person it's like
Canada cuz it would be murder now if he
breaks into your home now it's a
different story cuz if he breaks into
your home you are legally required to
flee your home
and you still can't defend yourself like
Canada and and and I said where would I
go I'm in my house this is where I live
and then what what I was told was when
you tell that to a judge you are saying
in court I would rather kill a man than
stand outside and that's the way the
court will will interpret what you are
saying and that is considered
unreasonable and they said only if you
are trapped and I said so if I'm backed
into a corner with no doors and a guy in
front of me I can shoot him then and and
what if he dies say okay that's the best
part you will now have an affirmative
defense after we arrest you and charge
you with a felony and you spend six
months in prison you can tell a judge
you were trapped hopefully he believes
you and I was like holy crap Maryland's
a little better if you are outside your
house Watering your lawn and a guy comes
up to you threatening you you must run
into your house if the man then tries to
break into your house this this is the
what I am told by law enforcement you
can then defend yourself so actually to
a much greater degree than New Jersey uh
but West Virginia by far is is is is
substantially better West Virginia you
can be on any property whether you're
indoors or outdoors and if you are
threatened you can defend yourself you
can't just shoot anybody this is not
true like someone walks in your property
you're like aha you know he's coming
right for me but if you are threatened
and you can justify the threat Florida
is even crazier and Texas too stand your
ground you know very little prob because
you could be anywhere legally you know
West Virginia also it it is still very
similar if you're in West Virginia your
constitutional care you're walking
around someone threatens you and you
have reasonable fear of of great bodily
harm or death you can defend yourself
dude I was in Florida uh last like three
weeks ago for for like three weeks and I
was I was feeling that the the the
concealed carry thing I was walking
around like at night and looking at
people I'm like they all probably have
guns just to everyone's got a gun and
they're looking at me and thinking he's
probably got a gun and we all just have
massive respect for each other that's
called her immunity yeah I mean that if
you are in a place where you can legally
carry a gun I mean I mean essentially
you are kind of rolling the dice like
that person may have a gun do I really
want is is the fact that he bumped into
me or looked at me wrong is it worth
making comment over because maybe it
escalates to something very bad and if
you're carrying a gun you definitely
need you have to know that you can't
just be like oh that guy's giv me a
dirty look so I'm just going to Mean Mug
him all night long because you're
responsible for de-escalating these are
things that you have to understand you
know exactly what one thing that always
bothered me growing up in Cho
is that I had friends who would road
rage and I'd be like people who weren't
from the South Side who didn't get it I
guess and they'd either come from
different neighborhoods or from the
suburbs we'd be driving on the highway
someone would cut them off and they they
they' switch the lanes get in the get
you know speed up and start flicking
them off and screaming at them and I'm
like bro do you know how many stories I
can tell you about a dude getting shot
in the face because he decided to road
rage out for no reason I'm not saying
that you know you you've got to you got
to back down I'm saying choose your
battles M you ain't gaining Nothing by
screaming at a dude in the highway and
swerving around if someone cuts you off
choose your battles just it happens man
don't get out don't get B out of shape
but dude some people I knew would rage
out and there's so many stories where
there's dudes with illegal guns now I
don't think they I actually don't think
the guns should be illegal to be
completely honest people who have
acquired guns in ways the state does not
like but you have a right to keep in be
arms that being said they they they
acquire these guns in illegal ways and
that means they do not have good
intentions and you can't defend yourself
from them because you can't have a gun
now because of uh DC versus heler you
can have guns but they still make it
near impossible and only recently I
think there's still issues with Maryland
Maryland was um was an in practice no
isue State meaning even even though they
say you can apply for a permit they
would never give you one New York was
similar New Jersey was similar now with
the latest was it bruan I think the
latest supreme court hearing they're
like you have to give permits if people
request one so uh now I think Maryland's
still giving people the business but New
York has started issuing permits so I
the the Catalyst for me leaving
Massachusetts and going to New Hampshire
was the the last draw was when I went to
the police officer and the went through
the whole riger Mo asked for a license
to carry and the issuing officer just
flat out said we don't give them out in
the town that I'm in and I'm like what
do you mean you don't give them out and
this is back in 2010 or so I want to
jump to the story from bearingarms.com
will scotus intervene in Illinois
assault weapons case is big news this
could uh look let me just first start
the segment by saying we're winning I
think more than half the country is
already in some form constitutional
carry though Florida only allows
concealed carry without a permit you
can't open carry which is interesting
but I think more than half the country
something like what 26 States it's now
constitutional carrying meaning if you
live in the state you got an ID you can
walk into a gun store you can say I'd
like to purchase a gun fill out the
federal background check form once you
clear you can buy the gun you don't need
a permit from the State however they're
trying to ban assault weapons and as we
learned in the documentary infringed
that just came out nobody even knows
what that means it has no Universal
definition and anybody who knows
anything about guns knows there is no
such thing as an assault weapon somewhat
similar to the what is the woman
documentary we went around and we like
interviewed everyone so what what is an
assault weapon and that is the right
conclusion we came to not a single
person could Define it it it works to
their advantage right
because State of the Union you know um
he was talking about shooting that
happen with a handgun yeah and then you
know at you know at the end goes ban
assault weapons now okay but you just
talked about a handgun people semi-auto
semi-automatic handgun people don't
understand that and and thankfully for
it but the people that are anti-gun for
a long time haven't haven't wanted to
educate themselves about guns and what's
unfortunate and what they're starting to
learn Now is really what they're after
is semi-automatic because that that's
what so so so so first I'm assuming 99%
of people who watch the show know what
semi-automatic means it means when you
pull the trigger a single bullet comes
out you had that great clip in infringed
of Michael Bloomberg saying semi-
automato they pull the trigger back and
it just goes not true let me read this
from bearing arms it's is important they
say today's Supreme Court arguments
focused on the federal prohibition on
firearms possession for those subject to
a domestic violence restraining order
and in the months ahead of the ahead the
court will hear cases involving the
atf's administratively imposed ban on
bumps stocks as well as a First
Amendment case brought by the National
Rifle Association against a New York a
New York official that the group
contends illegally pressured private
companies not to work with the
organization they're going to say that
uh now 2A activists in the Land of
Lincoln are ready to try their luck at
the Supreme Court once again this time
after the seventh Circuit Court of
Appeals recently overturned an
injunction and allowed the state's ban
on so-called assault weapons and large
capacity magazines to be enforced in
their decision the three judge panel
included that AR-15s and other arms
labeled quote assault weapons by
Illinois lawmakers are not protected by
the Second Amendment at all because
semi-automatic rifles are like machine
guns which the court declared are not
protected weapons in the H decision the
actual phrasing was weapons that are
most useful in military service M16
rifles and the like but the Supreme
Court has also said that arms that are
in common use for lawful purposes are
protected this could be big this could
mean that we finally end this stupid
fake assault weapon argument there is no
such thing as an assault weapon Now by
all means if they wanted to draft a
simple statement as to what an assault
weapon was let's hear it the issue
assault weapon is a nebulous term
intentionally used to scare people to
try and gain control exactly and you saw
this with like the Cody Wilson interview
the ghost Gunner right where he talks
about how the ATF are constantly playing
this cat and mouse game with him with
just the definition of a a gun a rifle
in general he's like in order to
restrict and control us they want to
make the po8 like that has to be a gun
the primordial form then he creates just
a block the 0% Receiver right now the
ATF is going to have to designate that a
gun in order to track that down and they
will they will keep changing the
definition because they want to be able
to control it at all costs possible 0%
receiv okay so it's a metal block it's
just it's just a rectangle of metal
and a CNC machine which basically Cuts
metal can cut it into a receiver yeah
it's a desktop CNC machine that they
make at ghost Gunner that you can buy
and then they you know if if if if if
you want to if you want to manufacture
if you want if you're interested if you
want to manufacture a lower receiver
with it they will send you the aluminum
Block in the mail and you just put it
the CNC and that's the story here is
that uh companies used to sell what's
called an 80% which is not a complete
gun but it's components of and the ATF
said no no because people can make a gun
with it it's a gun officially so ghost
Gunner just sells blocks and then the
the issue here is it's actually first
amendment that 3D printed guns are just
knowledge the knowledge or the file the
document that can make the weapon inform
the issue is that uh uh 3D printing and
at at home CNC cutting metal and stuff
it's it's cheap and ubiquitous so this
is the one of the big challenges that 3D
printed guns the cat's out of The Bag
Man exactly can't stop the signal it's
going to be crazy when they start like
registering USB drives as guns and I I
will say unironically unironically
exactly everybody should uh definitely
be get safety training you know don't
take this stuff lightly I just read a
crazy story where some guy in Brazil was
goof was was was goofing off like a
and his girlfriend was filming him
laughing and he pointed a gun at her and
now she is no longer alive guns see this
is the thing I feel like when Alec
Baldwin killed that woman uh hela hela
Hutchin with a gun the left defended him
saying it's not his fault and I'm like
the craziest thing in the world to me is
that the gun control people are saying a
dude who pointed a loaded weapon at a
woman and killed her had live ammo in
his belt it's not his fault and all of
the gun control people are like you are
responsible for whatever comes out of
the barrel of a gun you are holding it's
I'm like how are the gun control people
excusing this guy there are four rules
and that's it at the end of the day
there are four rules keep your finger
straighten off the trigger never point a
gun at anything that you know that you
wouldn't destroy treat every gun as if
it's loaded and know your Target and
what's behind it at all times if you
follow those rules no one dies period
well well sometimes well I mean if you
no one dies to be by mistake the point
is those are basic rules that you're
taught immediately all the time to
dramatically minimize stupidity which
results in people getting seriously hurt
however but let's just be real you need
to understand and respect firearms
because misfires happen like instructors
sometimes have issues uh there's a lot
of things that can go wrong no one no
one hates bad gun users more than other
gun users because they ruin it for
everyone no no one will be more
outspoken against the Alec Baldwins of
the world than you know the the donut
operators and the Brandon herreras who
want you to use your guns properly just
put a picture on Up of you holding a gun
with poor Trigger Discipline with your
finger on and you're going to be here
about it forever forever
exactly correctly when I was in
Egypt uh we had to go to the state media
building to get press cards so that you
wouldn't get arrested for being there to
walk into the State Building they have
armed guards standing on both sides of
the of the walled entrance and these
people do not have what is referred to
as muzzle discipline they're holding all
their weapons like this and so you so I
limbo I'm just like bro that 18-year-old
Egyptian dude holding an AK straight up
at head level I would rather limbo and
have them laugh than like walk past that
dude you know what I'm saying yeah I got
the internet I seen what happens most
people just didn't care and they walked
past him and I'm just like I'm going to
go like this and loop my head around cuz
uh but you have awareness around
Firearms like you are watching you
understand and that's even if someone
doesn't want to own a firearm having an
understanding of how they work is a
pretty damn critical skill tumbling
tumbling you see all these clips like
you know they'll uh you know they will
pull a trigger and the shot doesn't go
off and then they're like oh what's
wrong and then they look down the
barrel don't do that no weapons no I I I
want I want to stress the Alec baldon
thing they're saying they might they may
bring charges again but just understand
this when these liberal people want to
defend Alec Baldwin simply because he's
a liberal that listen just understand
this this is what we try to call out the
dude had reportedly live bullets in his
gun belt on his person he had a he had a
single there was a single action
revolver so you got to pull the hammer
back and then you got to pull the
trigger he lied about pulling the
trigger there was a friends conclusion
that the trigger had to have been
depressed the only way that it would
have fired there was a live round in the
chamber I say outright if you are handed
a gun and it can fire bullets you are
responsible for what comes out of the
end of it even if it's a blank yeah
exactly blanks kill people and they
don't they don't understand this and the
argument Alec Baldwin said was if I were
to have opened it to check they would
have rushed over and taken it from me
for tampering with it that makes no
sense Hollywood is broken if they are
handing random people weapons that those
people have not checked do don't follow
those policies that that gets people
hurt and we saw it with Alec Baldwin
there are I did a few videos on this and
there are um rules within like the
actor's guild and uh set workers and you
can go and read them and they're pretty
standardized most people know them and
it says both the uh weapons Handler and
the actor is supposed to check so I
don't know if if he said that that's
insane because that's a pretty standard
you can talk to any weapons expert in
Hollywood and they all will affirm
like bullets on set that is never okay
yeah that blows my mind how does that
happen I can't even imagine how that
happened they claim that people were
goofing off
ands and shooting cans with the guns you
are going to be using on set I'm sorry
what it is it is insane to me you get
all these liberals being like it's not
his fault he's just an actor and I'm
it's that mentality right it's not
hypocrisy it's it's hierarchy exactly
what are Hollywood people doing shooting
cans on their spare time anyway yeah he
was a producer on that film letting that
happen I want to I want to jump to this
story and uh get back into the more uh
partisan politics here this from the
post millennial breaking home of suspect
in the killing of an elderly Jewish man
at Pro Palestinian protest has been
searched by police for those that didn't
see the story otherly Jewish man was uh
I believe the reporting is he was struck
in the head by a pro Palestinian
activist fell down hit his head and died
get this first the breaking news on the
story is that they're searching for this
the search this guy's house take a look
at this tweet from end wokeness an old
Jewish man was murdered by a pro
Palestine activist the medical examiner
already ruled at a homicide this is the
media coverage CNN man in California
dies after suffering head injury at pro
Israel prop Palestinian demonstrations
here's one Jewish man dies after hitting
head in altercation here's one Jewish
man dies after alter
and here's another one Jewish man dies
from injury suffered in rally in Israel
Palestine rally incredible there was a
uh I think it was the daily mail I
tweeted this out said a uh elderly
Jewish man dies after falling and
hitting head it's just absolutely
incredible so I I went through all these
stories I want to point out something
else if you go to the Anti-Defamation
leagues extremism map the Nashville
shooter is not even listed so they all
claim in the media that the right is a
big threat oh the right wing the right
wing the right wing a completely
disorganized group of disperate
ideologies some that don't even agree
with each other that's the big threat
it's just random lone wolves when there
is something they call rightwing and
when you get the farle extremism they
don't even put it on the map they don't
track it and the cops don't go after it
they go after it in a certain sense but
they don't call it Terror they'll call
it just you know an unfortunate tragedy
or or something I don't know how to
explain how it feels being banned from a
country for hatred uh or what is it
racism because I called out Islam uh not
liking gay people very much had a pride
parade and then to see the same streets
filled with people like calling for
death are you you are you still banned
from the UK as far as I know yeah and
you you you you did like this popup
pointing out that Islam is
anti-lgbtq yeah so they said get out and
don't come back get out and don't come
back and then you have a bunch of people
that have immigrated there you know not
everyone obviously there are supporters
of Palestine that aren't chanting these
things of course but there were people
chanting like you know death to death to
the I don't know if I can like and other
groups I don't know what I can say on
YouTube these days but um yeah saying
these things and then none of them are
they're not even like citizens they're
not being deported and well did you see
when the guys were flying the English
flag the cops were like you got to put
that flag away it's inciting people and
then a couple guys were flying the Union
Jack which is the flag of Great Britain
not just England and they said look mate
there's more of them than us put the
flag away yeah and a lot of people were
like that's it when you can't fly the
flag of your own country in your country
because people who are not from your
country are threatening violence against
you that's that's a crazy Prospect I
think what we're seeing now with this
guy being killed and the bias look how
many how many Jewish or right-wing
protesters went to far-left events and
killed antifa guys it's it's it's not
happened what we see consistently is the
far-left engaging in acts of violence
and then they get excused by the media
the media acts like nothing happen and
know was there and then they say oh look
because there's no reporting on this
that proves the rights the bigger threat
Steve scales I believe currently has a
colostomy bag because he was shot wow by
a far-left Bernie bro uh supporter at at
the Congressional um baseball Rand Paul
was at that same very baseball game he
had to hit the deck for cover Rand Paul
has been attacked at his home he was
attacked walking uh in DC one time he
was attacked at his home there's the guy
that you were talking about today uh Jay
in uh yeah Eric Danielson in uh Aaron
Danielson Oh Aaron Daniel it was
Portland that that happened or yeah he
was shot you guys want to know something
really really really funny when you look
up the killing of Aaron Danielson on the
adl's website it says Michael ryel an
antifa activist shot and killed a
right-wing
extremist there's no reason to believe
he was an extremist at all he was just
some dude walking
and then there's Al angering more to the
point there's also the the kid that was
killed by the uh driver specifically
said that he was after him because he
was a trump supporter and I'm sure that
that is not treated as a political uh
murder because they try to talk it down
now and and in the 2016 election we saw
so many instances of violence against
Trump supporters I mean it it was it was
just ubiquitous but it was it wasn't
covered in the media and I U Mike
cernovich went to the White House you
know at at in in the Press beef briefing
room
and uh you know he just called it out
and they were laughing at him yeah
laughing at him that was a response
right but like you know we were saying
this stuff back then already look where
it is now yeah let me let let me pull
this up this from the adl's website it
says August 29 2020 leftwing Michael
rinal an antifa activist shot to death a
member of a right of right-wing
extremist group during a protest in
Portland unbelievable it's just it's
factually false so it was a guy walking
down the street there was no event the
event was over
and Michael rhinol who has a communist
an extremist tattoo on his neck walked
up to him and shot him twice in the
chest yeah that's in your do Crossfire
right yeah um yeah and and the way it's
framed it's like well this is an
anti-fascist person doing anti-fascist
things right that's activism yeah no
this was an extremist who sought out a
person on the right to kill but when
they when they continually lie cheat and
steal and obus gate these things now
look I'm not saying you know that the
right is more or we had this
conversation with Stephen Marsh on the
culture War he says there's more
seditionists on the right I think that's
actually factually incorrect I don't
know what he means by the right and he
couldn't Define it either and he said it
wasn't helpful and I agree with him he
was it was funny because he was
criticizing me for saying the left and
the right and I was like well what do
you say then because then he said he
goes look you keep saying like the left
and the right like what does it even
mean now when you talk to the right when
they say these things I was like right
there like what does it really mean we
don't know but I can tell you that what
we see in the Press always ignores let
me tell you the Summer of Love riots was
a mass death incident how many how many
deaths qualify for a mass death incident
more than three it's four I think
something 30 30 deaths in the Summer of
Love riots so what's the issue they have
to happen all within like 20 minutes of
of each other has to be white people
responsible then it gets to be so so my
point is this the riots were one thing
fueled by one thing led by people of a
shared ideology which resulted in the
death of between 24 and 36 people
that's a mass mass death incident
facilitated by the left and the issue is
exactly as as as as I describe it it is
is widespread Terror and blunt force
violence and when it reaches that level
people die now by all means be worried
and upset that there are you know uh uh
right-wing militias or whatever whatever
it is you're concerned about if someone
actually is committing violence or
threatening to do so we should stop them
what do we get we get the weird fake
kidnapping plot and then we get nothing
from ch chop you think the adl's
reporting on the fact that two guys
unloaded hundreds of rounds from a rifle
into a white SUV they don't do anything
I think you're right we need to be on
guard against farri extremism as well
because I think Chase geyser was saying
like if the if the pendulum were to
swing he feels I think he identified
himself he was on the show last night as
rightwing or whatever part of the
conservative movement or whatever that
if the power were to come back we need
to have a cool head like maintain you
don't want people to go nuts on in any
direction from any and like it's just we
got to make sure that we don't
radicalize people and they we're on
guard against radicalization it really
doesn't matter what direction I don't I
forget where I read this but I someone
was talking about violence and he's and
he said the people on the left treat
violence like a knob that you can turn
up and down and they'll turn it up and
they'll turn it down depending on the
politics of the day people on the right
treat po treat violence like an onoff
switch you're voting you're voting now
it's gunfight time and that's the that's
the that really does speak to the
character of people on the right and the
left the people on the right really do
want to work within the system and they
want to they want to they want to
believe in the system because they're
not nihilists the way that people on the
left are a lot of time people on the
right if they're not in in organized
religion they have some kind of
connection to spirituality and stuff and
so they believe in right and wrong
people on the left don't generally
believe in right and wrong and and we
had um I forget what his name when we on
the the the war the culture war on
Friday Ste Mar so he was talking about
he mentioned morality is meaningless
yeah morality is meaningless and so for
him it's it's it's clearly something
that is is not black and white whereas
people on the right tend to be like it's
not time for violence it's not time for
violence kill everyone in the room look
Ste steephen Steven Marsh I think he's a
good dude in the sense that he's he's
willing to come and have a conversation
but I think he's a bad dude with all du
respect because he said he believes
children should have access to these
adult material books I wish I was there
he doesn't care does he says morality
means nothing to me and I and I said
that's that's the problem right there
you have moral people who decide for
logical reasons some things are off
limits why well the people who are
exposed to Twisted content and and
twisted practices end up becoming very
very unhappy we're trying to reduce self
harm reduce depression maximize
productivity and happiness this is very
well recorded like you can look at uh if
porn is exposed to boys at very young
ages they tend to go for more and more
extreme things as they age to the point
where they have normalized like violence
against the other gender because that's
the only thing that can get them off now
and this is very well studied anyone can
look it up and yeah it's it's totally
has to do particularly with exposure at
Young ages where you don't really have
that decision-making skill prefrontal
cortex totally developed yet that's
actually when we were talking about the
news media trying to protect like the
the the guy who punched the dude that
died and it's like I can see that I
think that their idea is I don't want to
expose Society to the fact that it was a
a Palestinian guy or a guy that was Pro
Palestine punching guy that was Pro is
because they don't want to like twist
the minds of the people but I I I think
that's cover because if you I've talked
about this guy Herbert maruse before on
the on the podcast he wrote a paper in
theal man he wrote the book called
m-dimensional man but he wrote a a paper
an essay called that I believe he called
it on tolerance but it was essentially
it was called repressive tolerance and
the argument that he made in it was if
it is leftwing it is acceptable to be
violent and that it is okay because
you're doing it for a good reason that's
the long and short of it it's ridiculous
and it's childlike but it's also the
type of mindset that you see coming from
the left you see it in the media when
they they don't talk about things that
the left does or they or they talk them
down or it's not that big of a deal and
yet if the right the and one of the
things that he said is you should censor
people on the right at the level of
thought if you can control people's
thoughts then they will not carry out
violence and it like I said it's called
the the uh the paper's called um on
Toleration on uh repressive tolerance
it's worth a read it's not very long but
it it really does lay out the type of
logic that leftists tend to be to be
using when they apply to every and and
you see it in society now it's amazing
how they can create life or death
situations out of everything you know
you say it's a knob but like the I'll
notice with leftists they'll be like
you're trying to kill trans children and
that'll be like what they're saying in
their rallies and this is why we have to
have these extreme responses and I'm
like holy if you spent like one second
in the body of like just a 19-year-old
white kid in University experiencing
their life you would become a a Nazi
overnight you'd be like the oppression
I'm facing it's like nothing it's not
comparable you have the corporations the
banks the government the media all these
people on your side and you still think
it's a life or death oppression
situation imagine having none of that in
in uh in the documentary infringed we're
going to keep plugging it because we
want you to watch it you talk to a guy
in Berkeley you're going around asking
people at Berkeley do they want to ban
guns and then you finally meet one guy
who's like no and then he says he's a
gay Republican and then you're like do
you feel safe and he's like well you
know yeah kind of not really yeah I got
some questions about infringed maybe you
guys can answer them for me uh since you
did it how many guns did you fire over
the course of the shooting oh that's a
funny word shooting isn't that a weird
metaphor shooting the movie Shoot while
shooting your round count I I can't the
most guns would have been the
astronaut ranch right yeah yeah come
Ranch what what sounds intriguing tell
me more that's hell of a Tang
Lauren um I guess the shooting range
that Brandon and Cody go and shoot at
was actually like a NASA training
facility or something and they it's not
it's not at the range it's like it's
close by they've got like a yeah I don't
know if this is secret supposed to be
secret I I'm so sorry if I no I did
publish a bit of that yeah this is
Brandon Herrera and Cody Wilson they
assume that the astronauts were up to no
good while they were there so they call
it that oh that's funny I see so how
many total weapons do you think you you
sampled over
there or do I mean let's talk about it
let's get let's we'll say the one for
only I'd at least a couple dozen maybe
more 30 40 are they no it wasn't that
well I was shooting in Canada as well
and then we were shooting with STA and
uh oh yeah you're probably right it's
probably like aou yeah we shot like
maybe four or five in Virginia and then
at the at the ranch in San Antonio like
maybe 10 really I'm hyping things up my
head woman moment thing is they were
high caliber guns as well it was very
exting there was an anti-aircraft weapon
that we fired which was really was that
is 50 BMG I think it's uh there's only
like eight of them in existence they to
shoot helicopters but you can hold them
standing yeah that was I I don't know
what was that I think uh uh Brandon had
it it was a shoulder I I don't know
about guns it was bu like a Bullpup 50
BMG that he had on his shoulder and was
firing yeah yeah we both got to shoot
that that was like really crazy also
Hitler's Buzz saw Hitler's Buzz sawg
mg42 was very popular amongst
the and then it like gave me this really
bad rash on my arm there was a funny
hickey Hitler's hickey is what we call
that was the mg42 the hickey you guys
called it the hickey that's the mg4 so
they why do they call it the Hitler's
Buzz is that cuz the dude's in super
fast so it's the same gun that that the
Nazis used in World War II uh it was
just a different round back then so now
it's it's been changed to a Nato round
um but yeah you know it's the same gun
otherwise I mean it's super rapid fire
like in Band of Brothers where they're
like attacking Machine Gun Nest like
that's the gun the mg is the one it's
like a massage your whole body is like
shaking it's bizarre I will just say
real quick you can watch the full
documentary on
timcast.net do another one but we're
also putting a ridiculous amount of
money in marketing so just understand
this even if you don't want to watch a
documentary just as long as you know we
got an add up on Twitter I put up I put
up a clip a trailer for it I put $50,000
behind it it's not just about getting
people to watch a documentary Making
getting new memberships making more
documentaries the ads themselves are
activism if we can make a lot of money
off this documentary and then put out
advertisements that effectively advocate
for gun rights and normalize gun safety
and gun culture we are winning the
culture War so we want to do more of
this we got a whole bunch more plans so
definitely check out the documentary and
become a member don't miss it but I am
going to hard segue now to talk about
politics here and then we can talk a bit
more about that when we go to the
members only show we got the story I
love it we got good news in the Horizon
my friends when you see a headline like
this black lives matter leader endorses
Trump for 2024 election says the
Democratic party is a racist party that
strikes at the part of the black family
and the nuclear family so this is a guy
who helped Found A rad Island the Rhode
Island BLM chapter who is now advocating
for the rights of j6 protesters and says
Trump is the best candidate we have
Donald Trump is also leading Joe Biden
in five of six swing States so as of
right
now it's looked like it's looking like
Donald Trump's going to win for my
polling of my friends which is not that
many people but they're kind of Normy
it's like Biden's old man that's what
even the people that voted for him are
like this guy's just too old he sucks
too yeah but they don't want old he
didn't want old people they don't want
old people which is also like his same
argument for Trump like he's too old we
need new blood young men have you seen
the comparison of I've ranted about this
multiple times on this show but how old
the politicians are now compared to the
normaly like
before do we want Millennial and gen Z
politicians though I
mean it's all boers they have no
ties to the current struggles young
people are going through it's insane I
totally get that but I mean just you
know and competence levels right yeah a
38 he's a millennial I'll take it well
perhaps part of the incompetence that
has come from Millennials and Zoomers is
that none of the individuals older than
them are retiring and giving them the
power I think it is the the child
ification of humanity right that uh uh
people are staying as permanent children
so when I see these videos where it's
like ah adult thing it's so hard it's
like if you if you are someone who
constantly looks to the older generation
as if they're in charge instead of
looking to yourself as someone who needs
to take charge you will get this
phenomenon you know who's more
terrifying to me than someone who wants
perpetually be a child and there is
something terrifying about that is
someone who never wants to retire if you
never want to retire and you want to
hold on to power forever there is
something deeply but you can but you can
primary these people the problem is
they're running effectively unopposed
and young people AR
trying because what what what I see
happening is that they aren't even giv
the chot they aren't giv the resour it's
not about being given a shot you have to
just do it thing is my point is every
generation sucks right now except maybe
Gen X but they just don't they don't
care every generation sucks but uh
Boomers had like what 20% of the wealth
at at the age of Zoomers and Millennials
and like what 4% toally AG they got 186%
worse purchasing power yeah no I I
totally agree and the Boomers have a lot
of blame to shoulder for this but I mean
it it doesn't change the fact that you
know the Millennials are not really
capable of governing as a generation I
mean like you you have your you have
your exceptions like you know I think
you're selling Millennials short I don't
blame Boomers for having wealth I blame
Boomers for not educating younger
Generations this is nonsense it's all
lies I disagree with everyone here if
only Millennials voted in Canada we
would have a conservative majority
government boomers are more likely to
vote for liberals than Millennials and
Canada there is so much propaganda going
against the younger generation from
Boomers that want to hold on to power
and there are good Boomers I love you
guys don't don't worry but there's a lot
of bad ones that have a lot of power
right so I'm talking about the United
States right I'd have to look at the
data obviously I'm Canadian but there's
a lot of propaganda against the M are
looking at Boomers as if they're always
in charge instead of for whatever reason
like in my life I've had disdain for
everyone older than me all the time just
like it didn't matter who you teacher
you're awful you're stupid I'm I'm I'm
12 and I'm smarter than you even though
I know I'm really not I don't care
you're dumb I'm smart you don't get it
so I get older I'm like I've got to I've
got look they're they're doing it wrong
I can't s I'm going to go do it but
Millennials tend to be like well they're
the one who's the senator they're the
one in charge I can't do it it's not
that no Millennial is doing it it's that
Millennials in general have this
tendency towards assuming the older
generation are the ones who are supposed
to do it not them and I'm I'm talking in
general like you always have your
exceptions right but talking about yeah
do think there is a kind of sense of
giving up amongst young Generations
they're like the economy is so bad the
world is spiral and they they just kind
of yeah they've given it okay you guys
can do the no no I'm saying like when
you're when you're a child you ask your
parents for permission Millennials still
have that mentality that they need to
ask the Boomers for permission I I'm
like as soon as you turn 18 you're in
charge and you look the Boomer in the
eye and say shut your mouth I'm the boss
now start Mo but they have all of the
money they have
most of them boom so listen with all due
respect to Boomers one of the biggest
tropes was that Boomers didn't
understand computers and they would hire
these young people to come in and pay
them certain certain amount of money to
fix computers the money is available to
those who seek to to exploit an Open
Marketplace but Millennials are
permanent children instead of in of
seing to take over start companies
propaga too many Millennials are like
tell me what to do daddy well you know
what Boomers were Boomers opter parents
can't you I just going to say can't you
blame that on onom as well that's that's
what I'm saying Boomers did awesome
stuff and I actually think boomers are
great I think boomers are more based
than the millennial generation but it is
the Boomers who helped create
Millennials and create the culture and
and generated to the Next Generation Gen
X is actually probably the best and they
often the the reason why Gen X gets
overlooked in all the arguments is
because they're doing fine X had a great
everyone's like everyone forgets about
Gen X we're here too talk about it's
because Gen X is doing all right X was
around before the internet and like
teenagers when it got created so they
saw what it was like before this Mass
manipulation took over and they know
that it can be like that the Boomers
never really understood the internet and
people that were born with the internet
as a normality don't understand that you
can live without this manipulation and
you can use it to your advantage so well
well hold on look Millennials mostly did
not get born into the internet so I had
the internet since I was as long as I
can remember like my family the internet
in the ' 80s so we had Compu serve we
had dos shell all that stuff Windows 3.1
and even before that whatever and so I
grew up quite literally the internet was
always there most of my friends did not
get the internet until they were
teenagers gen Z however I think is
actually much more based than
Millennials though gen Z has its issues
for sure we can highlight all the weird
woke gen Z gen Z actually according to
Pew I think this was 2018 slightly more
conservative in a few areas so they're
comparable to Millennials but a little
bit more based and I think it may be
because because many of these people
growing up with the internet always more
so have a view maybe that you and I do
that it's a propaganda garbage fake
reality screw them I think one of the
things is really important was kind of
what you guys were saying is that the
generalizations aren't Fair because
there are some brilliant magnificent
leaders within every generation and for
a kid right now or human that was born
in like 1990 to hear us say people in
your generation are lazy they're going
to be like I'm lazy cuz they listen to
us and they believe what we say and
there're some great leaders yeah but
hold on be smart we're not saying
literally everyone we're saying there is
a tendency among certain generations to
have a higher proportion of certain
types and we got to figure out why if
you're listening to this you can be
better be better we need you to be
better be better but we also need to be
aware of what the time is like Tim is
you're an anomaly you're very successful
very talented on your own but most
people need support systems that are
really strong like I'm talking like
whole families like Italian soprano
style like we've got our own law going
on here um and that has existed for most
of human history that people have had
these clubs they've literally lived on
the same same properties with all of
their extended families and it was
really the boomer generation that kind
of started this idea of the nuclear
family get out of this house I'm kicking
you out you're making it on your own and
of course people are floundering this is
actually a phenomenon in human history
that people are being kicked out of
their houses at 18 and not kind of
handed a job from the dad from the
grandfather that they've been doing for
ages and ages given that dire and the
fact that they're a bit confused and
asking for direction should not be a
surprise at all this is a good point it
used to be and it still it still is in a
lot of ways I went to a maple farm we
went to Pittsburgh two weeks ago on the
way back we stopped at this 8 8th
generation Maple Farm we go inside
there's like when you go to the front
door the door is just open there's a
sign saying if you want to buy something
give us a call and I'm like man like in
the country right the store is open with
no one inside it just call us if you
want to buy something they're very
trusting old guy comes in plays a video
about how they make maple syrup showing
like old photos from like the 178 or
1800s when they were like making maple
syrup and he talks about how they had
this Farm going way back he got it from
his dad who got it from his dad who's
got it from his dead he brought his
daughters in his daughters are taken
over now and that's how it used to be
and then industrialization happens you
don't own anything anymore and so when
your kid gets older you say go find a
job somewhere else instead of the dad
being like son when you're old enough
you're this this this blacksmith's Forge
will be yours there is an incredible
rant on this in the second episode of
Fear and Loathing in New Jerusalem by
martyr made I don't know if any of you
guys have listened to the podcast but
it's very good and he talks about how if
you ask a man at a random Farm in the
middle of nowhere in the Middle East who
he is he's going to be able to tell he
knows exactly who he is he knows who his
family has been for thousands of years
he knows what his identity is what his
job is you are going to have a tough
time manipulating that man into absurd
ideologies whereas if you ask someone a
modern suburbanite in the city who they
are what did he say he said they don't
need existentialist philosophers there
they they don't need these people asking
who are we because they know we need
those people here because we are such a
diaspora we are so spread out we are
kicked out of our houses we don't know
who our families are we don't know our
history we don't have these lineages of
jobs and we're very easily controllable
because of that and very easily confused
because of that you get offered a sense
of identity in the realm of a new
radical ideology every single day on
Twitter Instagram YouTube You're Going
to be desperate for that because there
is nothing you are latched on to in this
world when you are kicked away from your
family and the closest people you have
our nuclear and there's nothing outside
of that
even yeah it's a big problem it's a huge
issue I noticed go for it I just want to
say that that one of the things that
that you're seeing nowadays or I think
you're seeing nowadays is the the fact
that human societies don't get to have
the option of not having religion so if
your Society has culture and religion
that's built into it then it's going to
have you know it's going to have certain
things that it does and and everyone
kind of knows their knows how to be in
the world right if you don't have that
if you don't have religion if if that's
taken away or you're you just abandon it
then you end up having Society replace a
religion that has foundations that works
often times with statism and that's what
you saw that's what nii was talking
about when he said you know God is dead
that's what you saw in the the Nazi in
Nazi Germany that's what you saw in in
communist Russia and China and it's
because
religion has evolved with human beings
and I don't think that human beings on a
societal level get the option of not
having it if you don't have a
traditional religion your Society will
replace it with something and you see
the bad things that happen when you go
when you try to replace what has worked
for your for societies throughout
history when you see it replaced with
new things and and attempts at new
things Nishi said when nii said God is
dead he wasn't saying that this is a
good thing he didn't know what was going
to happen he didn't know how people were
going to going to replace it and he
predicted the horrors of Communism and
Nazism he knew that it was coming and we
have killed him and now we're going to
go downhill yeah one of the things that
liberals liberals and I talk about
progressives when I say liberals I talk
about progressives one of the things
that they they tend to do frequently is
talk about oh it's good that nii you
know it's good that God is dead and and
they and it's we need to evolve Beyond
religion
but the evolution is the wrong word
first of all because you don't evolve
unless there's outside forces working on
you you don't it's like human beings
don't just change because it's it's
self-directed EV um self-directed
Evolution now so yeah trans humanism all
this stuff it's shown that it doesn't
work though it doesn't work for Human
Society it end it ends up it ends in
piles and piles and piles of bodies I
was thinking when someone is going to
develop their sense of self uh I can
only I can tell you what to believe but
you're going to need to tell me what you
believe and that's what I've noticed
about like indoctrination is like you
can tell people you can people can go
online and be told like this is what I'm
supposed to be this is what but until
they have an opportunity to express
themselves it's going to be challenging
to develop themselves and this is why I
like things like X spaces or
opportunities where you throw up a video
chat or an audio chat and people come in
and get the mic and then they express
what they believe and it's like you're
allowing people to develop themselves
and we need more self I mean that's what
a good parent will allow the kid to tell
you what they are I think if you're
constantly telling your kid what they're
going to be what they are it's like the
brain can handle it but they need you
need the entire core system to
experience you know the vibration of of
explaining what I am so more people yeah
it's the most basic act most basic Act
of Creation is to speak right yeah it's
like it's like the it's like the story
in Genesis right God spoke the worlds
into
existence and you know we're made in the
image of God so we have that same that
same kind of power you know what I mean
I I believe that's what that's what sets
us apart and uh so you know um when it
comes to things like censorship it is an
attack on that Divine image that you
have because you're not expressing
yourself that's it man the word it's
simatic there's like the literally the
vibration I'm into meta materials for
this like etching shape into your your
core your DNA and things with your voice
with the vi it's so important so I
encourage everybody out there to create
spaces to let other people come Express
themselves in your presence you better
you better drink that I think Tim's
going to kill me that $55,000 con cognac
is leaking through your paper how much
did you put in there it ate it way
through the cognac is so strong it's
eating its way through the cup and it's
dripping W does it taste like paper yeah
I'm getting this nice paper flavor Tim
has been looking at me like wor I've
never seen someone so angry in a stare
like not for the me for eyes I would
have just said no Lauren
don't there are glass cups over there or
maybe judgment she's doing it on purpose
because she got a bunch of people being
like no when she was drinking papy this
expensive what is it's p bourbon I think
right you know I actually like this it's
this is the first really strong drink
that I've been like I actually don't
mind you should just hold it up like
this and let it drip into your mouth
think of it as a filter it's a coffee
filter my CAC filter yeah it's just
dripping right out the corner there I
imagine there would there would be
whiskey purist that would have a
coronary if they saw that well they did
what happened Dr she didn't it's
supposed to be like an ounce in a glass
celebratory very expensive they like he
like a dropper to make sure they don't
miss a drop I'm going to get some we we
cracked this open when Elon Musk finally
acquired Twitter before it was X and we
were like huzzah you know we celebrate
yeah we all cheers and had a little bit
I don't think I had any actually why
shouldn't we be cheersing for the
documentary Che is cheersing I'm a very
cultured
woman but she was uh Lauren didn't know
what py was no and so she just poured a
paper cup like I'm just going to have
whiskey or something and then people in
chat were
like I'm G rinse mine out first yeah it
looks like someone had milk in there for
some Reas white stuff in here sirge
there's some white stuff in his drink so
you know remember the bus you showed me
earlier the that's that's what that's
what I'm thinking when when I see that
cup listen these are those are my people
it's perfect congratulations on the
documentary man you I'm super excited to
see this can we maybe we can watch a
snippet of it on the after show we got a
bunch of trailers and clips and stuff
we're putting Clips up and everything
but uh yeah there are some people asking
like why didn't you do like a big
theatrical release and all that stuff
and it's like yo this is our second
documentary game of money being the
first also available on
timcast.net like how do we do Red Carpet
Events how do we get like theatrical
releases uh police state D's film is in
in in many theaters wow uh s of Freedom
was we could we could definitely pull it
off but we got to get there we need your
support become a member maybe if this
one hits a benchmark we could do a
theatrical day a release day like one
showing or something I mean yeah like
honestly we could even though it's out
on the website we could still like rent
a theater and and do itol we should just
do it maybe it might take a month though
but we could go to a local theater and
easily just ask them like hey how much
to write the theater and then we'll sell
tickets to it we'd sell out for sure
that'd be great I think so I think
that'd be awesome it's a really good
like I remember driving by my local
theater and seeing sound of Freedom
playing and just getting this feeling of
wow like the culture is really changing
like when you actually see it in
everyone's face that you're driving by
like something that is culturally not
completely Progressive leftwing which
seems to be everything in Canada time
it's really moralizing I bet if we went
to a local theater and said we want like
Thursday Friday Saturday cheers and like
three showing showings each each day
we'd sell out every single showing yeah
you could because it's only a one time
thing people are going to come from all
over the area to come watch it most of
the time you can rent out theaters for
private functions anyways right you know
so I don't I think it'd be I think it'd
be easy to do somebody was saying to
sell DVDs too that they'd buy one DVDs I
usually do DVDs for all my documentaries
and people like to buy them there
actually is a market for it you assume
everything's going to be censored and
taken off the internet one day which
isn't entirely insane not just that for
people in Canada you know where they
where they don't have internet up way up
North or in Alaska where we don't have
you know actually we got to do it for
VHS Canada's very close to you having to
secretly slide a DVD under your jacket
to somebody to share information because
Trudeau's watching do you guys ever go
up to like the you is it the Ukon is
Yukon I I've no I've never gone up that
far that's like The Frigid North or
something I've gone pretty far up I like
the snow I like the cold I I love Canada
that's why it's so hard for me to like
consider leaving and everyone I know is
considering leaving right now that's
what Tucker doc doumentary was supposed
to be on the O Canada one that was cut
before he was fired filmed all ready to
go beautiful documentary so wait you're
saying we're going to get a bunch of
Canadians trying to illegally cross the
border into good A lot of them are
trying to go to South America that I
know um it's like it's actually El
Salvador the majority of people that I
know are discussing leaving the country
right now and it's actually really hard
is it because trau has a really creepy
voice that's exactly it you nailed it to
he's so annoying help anytime you hear
it on the radio it just I got that from
Kevin McCarthy I kept no I was going to
say he doesn't know how a man spread
either he doesn't know how he doesn't
know how to man spread like he does it
wrong he he just doesn't do it he like
oh he holds his knees together hold his
knees together as tight as possible it's
very upsetting it's really odd to watch
have you not seen pictures look up
Trudeau sitting it's like just look up
Trudeau sitting Trudeau sitting it's
like he's got a dime in between his
knees and he's holding on to it yeah
it's uh 1800 birthday there you go for
yeah one of the photos no this one
Shain that's the one right there no
there was a funny one TR that one with
Trump right there no there's there's a
there's very special one the one with
Trump is good though which one look up
CH sitting knees together cuz there's a
few of them I feel a little weird
looking up with these SE like that one
on the left like what the hell look at
him wow it's dangerous so weird petite
petite that's such a cute word I feel
like wait wait hold on hold on here you
go there he is that's the spread I saw
but I I looked up true do man spreading
I can't find one let's see if Google has
we got one right here there you go oh oh
that's legit Justin I just want to say
you got you got to learn how to
manspread man will go better for you if
you can do that is it true that he's
Fidel Castro's son absolutely 100% 100%
that that that's so wild people keep
posting photos of him next to Fidel
Castro like look it's him I feel like I
can leak this now now but a lot of the
maybe not but um the uh they did a
proper investigation into it with the
Tucker dog someone's got a oh like they
it was like kind of like MiMi but they
did actually like pursue that angle of
looking into whether he was Fox News has
it Fox News has it people you need to
pressure Fox News to release the O
Canada documentary it's incredible
should we buy a commercial for infringed
on Fox News absolutely people hate Fox
news though I just feel like it would be
a waste of well you got to save the
people there save them bring them over I
bet they would reject it for that reason
oh this smells so good by the way dude
you should do it just to see if they
reject it and then if they reject it
that's an interesting story in itself it
was like I think $122,000 to advertise
on Tucker Carlson but he was their
biggest show so right now I think Jesse
Waters gets like what like seven to
eight% is that what he's getting like 8%
of what Tucker was getting Tucker was
getting numbers how are their numbers
today comparatively to when when they
Tucker that I'm really curious because I
feel like I just forgot Fox News existed
entirely and never even thought to do
the
comparison uh let's see let's see I
don't I don't want to drag them if you
know I like Jesse Waters there are some
good people still there but uh Fox News
average
256,000 is that in the key demo so yeah
that's like half of what Tucker was
getting you know right so maybe it'll be
like $6,000 to buy an add- on Jesse wat
show or something like that so what you
do like pay Tucker directly to
shout for his X show now oh well he's
got an exclusive deal with with Public
Square I'm pretty sure oh yeah good deal
I think it's exclusive Public Square is
awesome they're very based we we we love
those guys they are winning the culture
War but uh Fox you just call them up it
was actually super easy MSNBC never got
back to me cuz we wanted to do uh we
wanted our pillow what we wanted to do
was a was a parody of my pillow where we
sell burlap sacks full of styr home
packing peanuts you packing yourself and
and you pack it yourself and it comes in
a box with instructions on how to pour
the peanuts into the into the burlap
sack and then sleep on it for the record
I think I found out what that white
stuff was in the glass soap cuz it kind
of tastes like soap I know this stuff is
soap pure sure
it's that's the wor offense in the paper
cup oh I got to go watch more yeah you
should I called Fox News and they
basically were like a single 302 spot on
Tucker carlon's like 12 something and so
I reached out to MSNBC in the same way
and they just ignored me interesting I
didn't I didn't say anything crazy MSNBC
I said I was looking to inquire
advertising you know I reached out to
their ad Network and all that stuff and
said looking for rates we're interested
in advertising and they just never
responded can you advertise on The Young
Turks uh I don't know how they do it I
do know that about 10 years ago I was
talking to Jen and I mentioned that we
had tried doing some ad campaigns
through YouTube on his channel and it
did not work and uh he actually like
asked me he's like tell like elaborate
and the issue was YouTube suppression
like why we were trying to promote a
documentary or something and I was like
let's put on a bunch of channels that
are doing political content and then the
data from ads on all every other every
other placement was good but Young Turks
was Zero across the board and so I told
him right away I was like hey man we we
did this big thing a bunch of channels
we saw like these cpms and this cost on
your channel nothing zeros across the
board and I don't know why that is
because we should at least get something
right and he was like YouTube
suppression you know most likely
something that affect not that I think
they'd be suppressing him these days you
know with maybe that could be a reason
why he's gone way more establishment cuz
he he saw the writing on the wall Maybe
monetarily and got scared I have no idea
people really uh you you can like really
mentally get trapped in this game of how
far establishment do I go to save the
political causes that I think are
important so I can still talk about them
and still get reach and like of course
there's a balance there where you can't
like go to jail and not be able to do
any activism at all right that's that's
pretty useless you can't run into
machine gun fire but there are so many
people that will keep making that trade
that kind of signing away their soul to
the devil until they've got points that
are Tire in line with every single media
industry every single big Corporation
every single government you know outlet
and they've kept they kept making those
trades for oh I need the eyes I need the
eyes and I think a lot of it comes from
Good Intentions I really do and then uh
it's just too late once looks sold out
MSNBC is up 12% CNN is up 16% Fox News
is down 13% these are in the ratings
yeah CNN is up so MSNBC CNN and uh
are up and Fox News is down are they
just up because Fox is down no Fox
viewers didn't go to MSNBC Fox viewers
left Fox News and they're watching shows
like this one or Crowder them firing
Tucker was the dumbest business decision
they've made in the last decade that I
that I've seen that was
crazy amazing what in the hell really
weird yeah but that was because of the
Dominion lawsuit I guess right they said
that they had to part of it was they had
to fire Tucker H that's crazy yo well
we're we're going to go to super chats
so if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button and head
over to
timcast.net
um looks like uh we got some super chats
cut off which really annoying that
YouTube did that they're cutting off
like the first 10 minutes but uh we'll
read what we
have uh Mark Jensen says I always
celebrate with writtenhouse whiskey ah
yes yes is that a real whiskey is that a
thing I believe it is good for Kyle is
he it has nothing to do with cut oh
that's so funny that's just a name all
right Andre caldron says holy F I just
finished watching infringed and you all
did an amazing job such a nice
documentary Lauren Southern was perfect
I encourage everybody to watch it very
important issue for the future and uh
you know I'm not going to I'm not going
to you know hide behind anything Lauren
outright says the documentary go buy
guns now like so it's like it is not
like a we're trying to be fair about the
issues of gun no no no we are we are
advocates unfortunately I only thought
afterwards that we should have had like
the sponsorship logos go up at the end
could have paid for the dog that way no
but it's not sponsored by anyone you
guys the viewer the viewer viewers like
you helped us uh uh fund this tremendous
documentry all right we're going to read
some more Mike oxar says just got back
from voting in New Jersey the reading
machines got jammed so they had us wait
half an hour just to put them in a bin
to be hand counted not sure what to make
of that but there you
go hm poly puree 9 minutes into the show
said fabulous show tonight I know thank
you very much thank you
Polly the sigp says Tim Might you
consider having the armed scholar on to
talk about 2A advocacy if Coleen Noir is
unavailable he's a based CA attorney
with a YouTube channel dictating the 2A
landscape in real time and works with
the with FPC and Goa uh I think that
would be really great for the culture
War podcast we tried to reach out to
call in for the documentary I just I
can't remember what happened there I
don't know if he's a busy guy yeah he is
he's got a standing invite to come on
whenever he can and we've talked to him
back and forth but uh I respect he's a
bus absolutely well we wouldn't have
reached out if we didn't respect another
person that if you're interested in in
2A stuff there's uh the four boxes Diner
uh YouTube channel um yeah I think they
people were shouting shouting them out
last uh Mark's he's a he's worked with
the Supreme Court he's argued cases
before The Supreme Court so he's a very
good
resource all right citizen 7 says I've
asked this before and I'll ask it again
freeing the source code sounds all well
and good but how is it possible to
verify the software in the machines was
compiled from the source code that was
made public oh he got you there Ian he
got you um well I me you could you could
put it on video of them taking the
machine downloading the the the data
onto a hard drive on a monitor while
it's downloading and have it all
publicly streaming it's AI though what's
AI it's fake you do that you'd have to
do that for every single machine yep
well let's just start by uh uh I don't
know that's a good question let's let's
get a let's get a a developer in here
and ask them the same question all right
we got Jason Hutchinson it says my
rights my property is not up for a vote
find me a politician that supports that
and I'll vote that is absolutely right
Michael M says it my rights are not up
for a vote agreed Michelle riddle says
Blame Canada shame on Canada yeah shame
on Canada shame on you guys for not I
don't know shame on you I Canada I love
Canada what's really funny is is that
infringed is actually a Canadian film it
is so true blame us for saving your gun
rights that's right we had to Outsource
to Canadians a documentary protect the
rights of Americans think about that we
understand what it's like to be muled by
a bear cuz you can't own guns on
National Parks actually happened two
months ago American gun owners are going
to be like Tim timcast outsourced good
American paying film making jobs to
these Canadians you the reality is we're
all Americans North Americans so true K
there you go yeah all right the dude of
bide says hey don't be trying to brag
about 1812 y'all got real quiet when
Colonel Jackson took a little trip down
the
Mississippi we almost took Montreal in
the War of 1812 why did they not why did
they stop short what happened I'm taking
Montreal because the British burned down
the White House oh
wow4 yeah you know the Canadians
actually moved moved their Capital uh it
used to be in Kingston Ontario which is
a lot closer to the border and they got
scared and they moved it to Ottawa
because you know the uh Coats were
coming yeah no it was like uh I think
guess and during the Civil War too
wasn't it like that I think we talked
about the step Marsh during the Civil
War the Union was like guys why don't we
just take Canada where we're at it for
real yeah and also the US took Mexico
people don't know this and then P gave
it back and Americans were pissed they
were like wait what why did you give
back Mexico it was ours like this
country would have been massive we
wouldn't need a wall we wouldn't be
having this
conversation
yeah all right neglectful sausage has
check thousand currents it's got
left-wing radicals on the board and
supporting it the Thousand talents
campaign is Chinese so what's thousand
currents isn't that uh what thousand
currents is that CH yuger thing was that
what that was thousand currents I don't
thousand Curr is bold solutions for
climate food and economic Justice sounds
awful sounds communist it's too bad
because those things would be cool if
they didn't get co-opted I just want to
say this right now so uh you know
Brandon Herrera tweets out he X posts
check out the documentary and links to
it and Shout out really do appreciate it
and then someone someone responds to it
I'm not paying for that tell timcast to
upload it to YouTube and I was just I'm
sitting here waiting for someone to say
it because I know they're going to and
I'm like I got you and then I
immediately call him a communist like I
got him I was waiting for someone to say
just make it free because they did that
the daily wire the daily the daily wire
puts out one of the most important
documentaries ever takes the country by
storm the world what is a woman and all
these people are like give it to us for
free it's important give it for free and
they're like yo it costs us a ridiculous
amount of money to make this all the
crazy work all the employees and so it's
funny that you know here here we are
supposedly the capitalists and there are
people saying that we should give it
away for free okay let me just say
something I believe in the cause in
order for the cause to succeed the cause
needs resources if we want to make more
documentaries we need money if we spend
six figures producing a documentary and
then don't get any of that money back we
can't make another one because we don't
have money like you got to pay for a you
know what I mean I like I like to eat I
like I like to feed my kids very true I
uh I did this for years I did my first
three documentaries and published them
all for free and there's a reason I'm
here now working with Tim and not still
publishing documentaries for free
because guess what I don't make any
money to make new documentaries when I
publish them for free so I'm actually
really thankful I wouldn't be able to
make another one if I didn't have the
funding the resources and so here's what
I'm saying not only did it cost a lot of
money to make but we want to Market it
to too we want to blast this off we want
it all over Facebook all over YouTube I
want some regular like 24-year-old dude
playing video games to Open YouTube and
get a commercial for infringed and then
to see like Lauren laughing and hanging
out with the guys and they're talking
about gun rights safety and and 2way all
that stuff we want to make it ubiquitous
and common that Americans are all about
this we want to make it popular the
other thing is these YouTubers they're
going to see a big spike in their
revenue and they're like oh what's this
all about and it's going to be like oh
you've got commercials for this
documentary and they're going to say oh
wow bread and butter baby if we run
these commercials we make money can I
select to have that ad run on my
videos I like this ad usually it's just
got an I don't like this ad option yeah
we we as The Advertiser choose where to
put it put them on my videos we just we
we put them on we're going to put them
up everywhere YouTube was a lot harder
it took like I don't know eight hours to
get approved which is like fairly normal
uh on X it was like 5 seconds I was like
promote it was like under review and
then I got an email being like yeah
you're you're good yeah and you know if
you have friends that aren't the kind of
person that are going to pay for a
documentary like this have a little
viewing party get a timcast membership
invite your friend over make some
popcorn watch the movie with them yeah
it's a it's a great movie to watch with
people start discussions it's uh and we
made sure to it's it's really difficult
sometimes to make movies that are really
highly like data history filled
entertaining but we went on the ground
we shot the guns we went to Baltimore we
went to these places we keep it Dynamic
I hope we make at least 2x the our costs
back I hope I hope we get 100% you know
or like a 50% margin I guess you'd say
then we'll make two documentaries right
this is what I'm saying if if we you
know make spend all this money and make
back two times the money we'll make two
more documentaries and then we'll make
four more documentar we'll keep just
building content making shows and and
and doing allu one other thing I liked
about the infringed I saw the trailer
was that it seemed kind of nonpartisan
like it it started off this particular
trailer explaining like gun violence and
how horrible it is and then showed like
you know the antidote and like actually
self-defense can help you defend
yourself against gun violence and I
thought it's just a brilliant way to
look at it yeah you don't like you don't
have to deny that there are horrible
things that can be done with guns you
don't have to deny that there are
negative sides to it to talk about why
you need a write to them like that the
best arguments are one that acknowledge
all sides and still say this argument
comes out stronger right in my opinion
anyway let's read some more we got legma
who says if you get scam calls or texts
or whatsapps respond with a text
including things like tenan Square
Taiwan Independence and other for terms
on the Chinese internet you will have
your scammer essing his pants and also
Force Chinese Intel to look into it uh
it also may it could result in them stop
calling they stop calling you the
problem is a lot a lot of a lot of these
calls are Robo calls but if you're
getting messages I suppose that makes
sense Chinese oh I wanted to mention as
well infringed can be a drinking game as
well if if you want to watch it every
time someone fires a gun you take a shot
oh no no no no no no like and when it's
a machine consult a doctor before before
getting drunk you'll be drinking so much
prob tell you not take uh that kind of
activity ew says Tim I would love to be
able to buy a hard copy of infringed I
have purchased all of Lauren's
documentaries on DVD the one I would
really uh this one I would really like
on DVD okay we'll figure it out let's
let's get it who is that uh ew Super
Chat then we will uh we'll start looking
into it I'll have to send a message to
somebody but we'll see we see if we can
figure this one out and uh maybe we'll
just start like burning DVDs and then
mailing them out in like sleeves just
like hand Sharpie INF Fringe that would
be cool that's a really great marketing
idea if you wrote infringed on all of
them then it's like hand signed by you I
have the worst handwriting
ever 10-year-old boy that's dyslexic my
handwriting tell me more all right
Ian I print everything perf personally I
don't do
cursive that was when I realized the
school system was Bonk in fourth grade
when they're like you have to write this
in curso and I just stopped and I just
started Printing and they never said
anything about it I was like oh I own
these guys Amanda says a big reason
Canada did not join the founding fathers
in the Revolutionary War was because
there were many French Canadians who
were catholic the US was mainly protest
Protestants who hated Catholics right
right yeah wow yeah there's a big French
influence in Canada I love the language
police it's so hilarious they're like
our culture is
dying Doom 92 says Tim you're not
showing up on my sub I had to look for
you yep that's the way it goes man
that's the way it goes they're trying to
suppress us one thing that happens and
many of you may notice this when we go
live there will be no
thumbnail of course we make thumbnails
every time yeah and as we're producing
the live stream we put the thumbnail in
it and then a bunch of people will be
like the thumbnail is a gray box uhhuh
and I don't see that happening to
literally anybody else but what happens
is when people are on the front page and
scrolling and it appears there and then
people are looking for the image and
they don't see it they don't they don't
click it yeah exactly or someone who
doesn't know the show is might see the
thumbnail is interesting what happens
then is they can say it of course
appeared on the front page it only got a
few clicks though they're they're
playing dirty games I heard that if you
post more than four videos a day on a
channel they stop notifying you for the
fifth one Beyond so if we put up four
Clips could that could be the issue it's
not about notifications it's that some
people can see the video like we'll go
live and it'll be on our Channel and
they'll go to the channel and it's not
there oh and so they'll have to look for
the UR the direct url url posted by
somebody else right one person mess
super chated saying that like my friend
had to share the URL with me so I could
watch it because it wasn't appearing on
YouTube yeah like people are going to
their actual live tab itself on the CH
the channel and don't find anything it's
happen to me as well so well crazy I'm
wondering if we should just start
dumping tons of money into placing the
podcast on places just because you know
it's like yeah all right Fred Coler says
Lauren sweet Canadian move to South
Omaha instead we have grapefruit and
bacon and all wear baseball hats made
from graphing love that sounds great I
really like the cold though I'm a big
fan of the cold what that was what he
was saying too I don't get it I like
having a big fire I'd prefer to get cozy
and have like a hot drink than be
sitting in front of a fan I love
sweating Lis Vasquez says I signed up
for the Miami event it was great we'll
watch infringed tonight any news on the
Apple version of the timcast app would
love to see the members shows in my TV
thank you Apple takes forever the app is
done it is in the hands of Apple the
Android app is currently available for
download you can download the timcast
Android app right now and uh read
articles and watch all the news and
everything fast too I love it it's a
good app you can put the show on and
then you can suspend you can you know
turn the display off and still listen to
it and all that good
stuff here we go John Sarah sanguinus
says 2 million gun owners in the state
350,000 couldn't be bothered to sign a
ballot initiative or come out to vote
gun owners are a joke dude gun owner
doesn't mean gun rights activist or even
conservative or libertarian there are
woke liberals who bought guns and then
turned the TV onto the Simpsons and
didn't watch anything political they
don't know they don't care the funny
thing is when the US government changes
laws especially gun laws without telling
anybody one day there's going to be a
knock on their door and they're going to
be like we see in the gun registry that
you're an owner of an AR 15 well that's
an illegal ATF controlled weapon and you
are now a felon and they're going to be
like huh but I don't watch the news too
bad I was literally telling the story
about how that happened to me like when
I was I got my first gun at 18 years old
and it went I shot it a little bit and
then it went under the bed cuz I spent
the next 10 or 15 years in a van and a
bus touring and stuff and then I pulled
it out when I was you know 15 years
later or whatever and uh I realized oh
my goodness I am not up to date on all
the actual legislation I had to go and
do all kinds of jumping through the
hoops and and when I initially got it
all you had to have was an FID card and
that was supposed to be good for life
and they changed the rules so right you
have to stay up on those kind of things
thing too is is the
um the ATF uh they they use back doors
on websites where you buy things for
your gun like accessories and so you are
already probably on a list well I mean I
have item so I got silencers and short
whatever so I'm definitely on multiple
lists definitely that on timcast is
helping I mean I put it I put them up on
Twitter and stuff I'm I'm I'm All Above
board I'm Legit so feels the L I always
have this like little dance where I'm
like oh I want to talk about these
things because they're fun Should I
maybe I'm in Canada though and it's like
you might as well go one or the other
yeah I mean I I agree but you know it's
like I like I said I've I've been a
proun guy and put pictures up on Twitter
and stuff forever so you know how the
government sent out that text like world
like Countrywide about like hey we're
just notifying you this is our emergency
text thing do you think that they should
be mandated to do that for changes in
laws no your phone would never stop
bringing that's that's the problem
Omnibus Bill passed could sleeping all
night opt into a number that they could
text you on if you wanted updates on
every law that gets changed I don't
there's not a benefit to them because
anytime that you're in violation of a
law or whatever if they can use that
against you they're the government
doesn't have a lot of of desire for
people to be aware of the laws and and
up to date on if they're breaking the
law or not but it's it's a benefit to me
and I am the government we are the
government I should say we as the
American people that is the that is the
goal that is the intention I'm Canadian
and that's so true we're your secret
shadow government know Matt Kelly says
nice to see a guest who who dresses
formally on this show thanks for
representing the Canadian tuxedo looking
forward to watching the
documentary it's a beautiful corduroy by
the way no that's that's the can tux
that's the Canadian tuxedo that's right
both of us are dressed like bombs which
one of us is it it's almost you needed
the denim shirt I I did I have one and I
thought about bringing it but I
literally was going to wear a flannel
today but then I was like Lauren's here
and then like she's going to think that
I'm making fun of Canada so I was like
Lauren I do not look like a bum I hugged
you earlier and it felt good that cury
it was nice I can't believe we let him
in here that's really nice of you guys
yeah SM it's great that you're doing
charity
work Adrian Curry liked that let's grab
some more Super Chat what's up woot do
for you says I was put on ssris at 12
years old institutionalized at 17
diagnosed bipolar with suicidal and
homicidal Tendencies I'm a gun owner
however I've had at least two feds try
to get me to do a shooting none of this
is a joke yikes what
crazy someone stay strong someone check
in on buddy yeah I mean you could do a
whole dock on the SSR
and and and mass shootings right I mean
I remember there are a lot of weird
instances I've had like I remember the
first time I went to M and Beak at
Brussels and I was doing interviews and
this guy this Muslim guy was talking to
me and he's like I went to jail I swear
they tried to get me to do a terror you
know incident he's like I promise like
this is what happened they were like
torturing me and I'm like like I can't
prove this so I can't publish this but
this is pretty wacky man like I don't
know why you'd come up to me and just
start saying this I don't know I know
nothing well yeah you know that sort of
thing relates back to MK Ultra and like
the 50s and 60s and you know it's in
their documents where they were saying
like we we want to develop a mind
control system so we can actually have
an asset commit an assassination like
they admit that that was the goal and
then so then you have you know you have
guys like Saran Saran who shot RFK
saying that you know he was under mind
control you know well what's crazy is
they've got technology to make it so
that you can hear things like Hear
Voices but only you can hear them in the
room like have you seen that there's
viral video there's a viral video going
around of a professor showing a
classroom where he's like got this
speaker that's like a direct speaker
that'll make it feel like you're hearing
things and there have been shooters that
have been like the voice kept telling me
to do this The Voice kept telling me to
do this this this last shooter like what
a week or two ago Robert card uh there
was something like he went into you know
oh yeah the the guy up been man yeah he
had like those those in ear things
because he had bad hearing or something
I don't know if messing this up but and
he was saying that he was hearing voices
right yeah a lot of them are on ssris
too the original Night Stalker too was
say was telling people that his dog was
telling him he was hearing his dog talk
to him I think his name was Richard
Ramirez was in the's a here's a good one
Jordan mcclown says duty to retreat when
you flee your house just to go break
into your neighbor's house they're
required to leave that's how absurd it
is someone breaks in your house and
you're like ah I'm forced to flee and
then you break in your neighbor's house
and you're like I can stay here now I
love that the duty of retreat chain
effect where everyone has to move out of
their house eventually cuz the person
beside them that is so dumb that is so
dumb do not break into houses anyone and
move to states where you can defend
yourself it's even better in Canada it
has to be like a last effort mistake if
you shoot someone so like first of all
you have to accidentally unlock your gun
take the trigger lock off then you have
to accidentally find your ammo and like
slip it into your gun and then you have
to accidentally like slip and fall into
your gun and then shoot the guy cuz it
was like the last resort what is this a
AR says half of Australia is without
internet and phone service banking in
emergency phone service affecting 10
million the cause is unknown is that
true so I want to look that up yeah what
is Australia austalia would not surprise
me
H Australia phone service Australia
isn't a real
country this is six hours ago Opus
outage leaves millions of Australians
without mobile and internet wait this
they changed the name of the article uh
says some key services are quote
gradually being restored after hours
long outage affecting Australia that
means that they're not restored if
they're gradually restoring them right
now without mobile and
internet wow oh no the not real fake
country that's upside down is having
trouble with
internet I wonder if some Wingnut says
switch Alec Baldwin for James Woods come
on now yep if it was James Woods who
pulled a gun they'd be screaming see
guns are bad it's his
fault
crazy we'll grab some more we'll grab
some more Terrence Max says Canadian
here just got my pal I'm getting the
hell out of Canada once I'm released
from the Army Canada's military is an
absolute joke they're so desperate
they're getting permanent residents to
join shout out to Lauren the Canadian
military are a joke all the Canadians
quit and the Canadian military is made
up of non-citizens they will enforce
whatever law they're told to against
anyone dude when they stop on the
trucker protest that's like the heart of
the country those are like the most
hardcore Canadians yeah oh I have some
stuff I could say about the military
after this
podast the Canadian military are yeah
something else I I would love to help
reinvent the American Military Canadian
United States like really bring some
patriotic super soldiers to the
table yeah they're called yeah there
there's a lot to say like she was just
saying there's a lot to say about uh the
military the RCMP yeah Canada I mean
it's being hollowed
out um yeah ply pure says boomers are 54
to 69 the silent generation is 70 to 85
it's the silent generation in charge not
the Boomers that you're referring to
some members of Congress a lot of the
older ones but a lot of industry is run
by Boomers right the people who are CEOs
silent generation in charge I rarely
hear that too well I think Biden's
silent generation way really was it
start in 49 is when the Boomers started
something yeah I'm pretty sure Trump and
Biden are both silent generation wow yep
Sleeper Cell silent
generation that's right 46 is so so
Trump's right on the cusp he was in 46 I
think y Putin she all of them are silent
generation the commander says Tim I have
this Theory check my thinking on this
now that Michigan and Ohio have
enshrined abortion in their
constitutions that means liberal single
women will calm down and not vote in
2024 handing those states to Trump
I don't even think that matters I think
it's the economy stupid right the old
famous saying people just want cheap gas
and their bread cost too much money
that's it the the inflation stuff is is
probably what's going to have the most
effect on the most people because issue
by issue there's certain voting blocks
that it matters to the economy hits
everybody so cheap
fuel let's do
it these super chats are awesome by the
way yeah let's grab some more Super
chats we uh we can grab a few more
more what do we got uh what do we got
467 Sprite says AO from OC SoCal also
yes saw a z zany granny Z what is that
in the freeway Pro Ukraine sticker and
an anti-trump bumper sticker I think the
younger youth would be that Red Wave
Whiplash once the old heads phase out
maybe I don't know what do you
think I'm not so sure I I don't feel
like the younger Generations are
actually more conc conservative uh I
mean I'd like to Hope but I'm not I'm
not super confident that there are more
it feels like cope to me yeah you know I
I be wrong yeah the the Pew research
from a few years ago was that jenzy and
Millennials are almost the exact same
but jenzi is like a percentage point to
the right on some
issues so it could be a reversal all
that really matters that liberals don't
have kids that's it right and people are
like yeah but they're indoctrinating
your kids and it's like yeah but that
can only go so far it doesn't matter
right it's how they reproduce through
the school system and indoctrination but
I mean at some point it you know
literally doesn't matter and people are
like I know conservatives and their kids
are sotally totally woke left I'm like
yeah that happens but it literally
doesn't matter like you can only
indoctrinate so much which is why
there's a whole they're opening up the
southern border because they know it you
can indoctrinate adults too and then
they'll indoctrinate their kids
right Kevin O'Brien says all they needed
to do was let Trump win the 2020
election they would have had a year left
of at this point now they will need to
deal with him for another 4 years lol
and uh the Revenge that he
wants so Trump's gonna go ham baby all
right what do we
got let's see sir Alexander fall says
hello Laura Tim and Friends Canadian OG
YouTube Toronto dundis Street Church
Pastor David Lynn has been denied
re-entry to Australia after starting EV
after starting evangelizing Church there
h
h interesting Keith LEL says I don't
want to run a country state or District
I want to do my job and raise my
kids you know I'll tell you I love the
movie The Patriot with Mel Gibson
because he keeps saying no war no war no
War I will not vote for war I'm going
home and then the war comes to his house
and kills his kids and then he's like oh
wo is me and then he takes up arms and
he goes and
fights it's just a story though you know
same thing in rart man it's like M
Gibson was trying to tell us
you know first thing goes I just want to
raise my crops yeah leave me alone man
minding my own business and they're like
nah we're going to we're going to mess
you up it's like fine but that's the
brutal thing that's why it's a good
story it's like these these are good men
who are like please we do not want war
in Conflict the problem
is you know you got to hope for the best
and prepare for the worst and if you're
not prepared it's a brutal movie but uh
the Patriot with Mel Gibson one of the
best movies ever made my favorite by the
way hm Kenneth har says Tim stop it
you're scaring Ian look at him he's
shaking right now calm down Ian oh was
that in reference to me standing right
behind Lauren well actually I was
kneeling right behind Lauren while she
was I have no idea maybe it's this wavy
shirt just looks like I'm shaking Dingle
oper says shout out to Scott Pressler
for joining us on the timcast Discord
last night check out his app and his
website early vote action very cool
really awesome to have uh Scott presler
hang out on the uh Discord
server comedy says Tim andan I'm
building a new 40K Army should I build
and paint a grey Knights Legion or
custus what is that do you know that one
I don't know it I'm not super versed in
Warhammer custodes yeah love you guys
and thank you for your work I have no
idea I'm Eldar all the way also tyranids
if you want to rock get those Jean
Steelers they're like the ant creatures
that are psychic those things are nasty
I will say my favorite part of the
infringe documentary is when Carl
Benjamin reads the Second
Amendment it's like we need a British
guy to read the Second Amendment because
the assumption is the Founding Father
sounded British but they didn't I fig
it's so funny because it's like oh we
just get a random British guy but he is
the most distinguishable voice you've
ever heard like there is no way you
cannot know it's him everyone's seeing a
Sargon of a cad
video gry says don't make me hard Buck
buuck the documentary is very good it is
very good thank you Adam Smith says Gen
X are the Zoomer parents mostly it comes
and goes in waves there's some bleeding
uh bleed over between Generations but
yes Gen X made the boers which is why
genz is I think j z is is more based
than Millennials I think Millennials are
the
worst yeah Boomers I Millennials are
awful Gen X is right and gen Z is Right
aren't you a millennial yes you're
hypercritical on your own generation
yeah you're Millennial too aren't you
I'm like the very end I'm hypercritical
on I still speak jenz I'm right on I'm
very early I'm what they call an an
elder Millennial so I'm you know it's
it's like how old you uh 1984 four oh
okay right yep so that's
uh it's sort of like half Gen X half
Millennial year of X zenal zenal yeah 79
is the last year of X so I don't
identify with Gen X really I identify
way more with the people that are born
in the 80s I'm a millennial and I think
Millennials are awful but I'll tell you
why so uh I have like a five-year head
start on Millennials when I my my mom
was homeschooling me before I started
grade school I worked for my family's
business when I was like 9 to 11 years
old so I have a a much like I was a few
years ahead of everybody else in terms
of working having a job uh being online
being involved in politics I was like 13
when I was reading political news and
talking about all the stuff and so all
the kids around me were were not doing
any of it so you know I'd probably have
a closer to Gen X perspective based on
on that alone but I don't know it's
interesting it's just it is what it is
get a job when you're 12 that was very
Gen X my mom made me do that yeah all
right everybody smash the like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends go to timcast.net
who supported me through it all thank
you so much all of the people who
support me on uh subscribe star not
patreon cuz I'm banned from that right
on right yeah what what she said
basically um you know thank you to all
who signed up and watch the doc that's
how we can make more of this stuff and
uh you know make a dent in the culture
War I'm looking up your subscribe Star
right now Phil what were you going to
say I am Phil that remains on X I am
Phil that remains official on Instagram
the band is All That Remains you can
follow us on Instagram or no you can
well in stagram yeah uh you can follow
us on Spotify app Apple music Amazon
Pandora YouTube you know the internet
people want to go to your subscribestar
docomo Southern a thanks and support you
there thanks for coming on that oh cool
I'm Ian crosslin thanks for the liquor
it was delicious a little soapy I think
but maybe it's just my my imagination
was a little papery so we're we're we're
eting making it happen hey follow me on
the internet what's that t that's like a
$100 ring of liquid on that posted
poster it was cool it smelled like
I liked it maybe it was the Canadian in
the room I'm I've had the most unique
paper flavored expensive cognac anyone's
ever had they're all doing it the boring
way I interviewed a dude on my YouTube
channel today uh God I got your name
right
manes uh you got this dude he's the best
go check it out we talked about reusing
spent nuclear fuel he's a rabbi you guys
are going to love this conversation so
subscribe to me on YouTube follow me
there that sounds sick dude nuclear fuel
reusing with Rabbi
and and Ian can you guys end by speaking
some of your native tongue
alans sounds so fun they made it
up anyways yeah let's go to the after
show all right we'll see you all over at
timcast.net
I